e e
you're awesome thank
you all right like to call this uh
session together we'll open with the
Pledge of
Allegiance representative Flanigan can
you lead
us flag of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all and Mr clerk can you call the rooll
please representative avalani pres
representative
Flanigan representative
Prout representative Warden here
representative
Drago representative
Granger representative Fairington here
representative Hall
here the clerk is here representative L
here representative
Sullivan representative
Sullivan okay representative
kahill representative D
sylvestro representative Susi here
representative bushard here
representative McKenzie here
representative
Schultz representative lir here
representative St here chairman kraton
here all right and seeing that we have a
quorum uh we'll go ahead and get started
let me just refresh everyone's memory
what we're doing this morning uh as you
recall two weeks ago we looked at uh HB
542 and HP 744 in detail uh there were a
couple of questions that were brought up
which required amendments and uh so
representative McKenzie's done a lot of
work to uh
amend those bills and so we thought that
it would be worthwhile for us to take a
hard look at those amendments and uh see
where those bills could go from there
and so I open I opened the session on HP
542 uh this
is based on a resource recess that we
did two weeks ago and representative
McKenzie if you could go through sort of
a recap of where we were at and then
what your Amendment does I'd appreciate
that all right sure enough Mr
chairman so the original uh legislation
uh had six additional steps at the top
end of the
scale uh we have uh this particular
piece of legislation the amendment will
if the member could suspend and you're
you're in testimony now so because we're
in a hearing so if you can uh sit at the
the witness I think that'd be uh more
appropriate thank you
good morning Mr chairman my name is Mark
McKenzie I am a representative from
Hillsboro District 40 in
Manchester and I'm here this morning to
introduce uh the amendment
to uh HB
542 uh the amendment uh as drafted is
differs from the original um bill in the
sense that it takes back uh six of the
uh 12 steps that were
proposed the current schedule will go up
to um
52,000 uh would in uh at the rate of
$535 will be the top of the scale uh
currently the top scale ends at 415 at
$427 now the uh initial uh
legislation uh and I think I shared with
you the amendment fiscal impact of the
amendment uh the the original uh the
original Bill uh was more was a reach
and very difficult I think to uh uh
given there would be no tax increase on
the other side it would be a difficult
uh thing to achieve uh but I think what
we've done is to strike a balance and I
was kind of hoping the UI people would
be here this morning but what it does is
strike a
balance so the proposed uh Amendment uh
stays within the lines in the sense that
it uh does not break the fund uh and
there is a I don't know if everybody has
this in front of them but you kind of
get into weeds with this let me let me
go through
it the the system uh tests uh when they
do a stress test on the system they do
it by looking at what's known as a mild
recession uh and a major
recession and the original Amendment uh
put too much stress on that on the
system and so if you look under the
forecast for the mile
recession uh what that has done is to
scale back
uh so that under a mile recession the
fund would would finish at 237 million
keep in mind the current uh balance in
the fund is I think about
$380 or $85 million right
now uh what you don't want to do when
you look at passing any kind of benefit
increases you don't want to get to the
point where the system is in a negative
draw because at that point you have to
go to the federal governments you have
to uh draw money down uh and borrow
money actually from the federal
government so this amendment avoids that
uh even in the times of U uh impact of a
major recession now this doesn't mean
it's going to happen but the way that
they approach the funding of the bill
they they do it this way so that you
understand that what could potentially
happen so even um even under that uh the
impact of a major recession the fund
would still be in a position where they
would would not have to borrow uh so it
would finish I think at in
2026 at 200 uh 42 million if the major
recession uh were to
occur so what you have here is uh is an
amendment which I I think presents an
opportunity to increase the unemployment
benefits and keep in mind the employers
are at a 30-year low in terms of that
tax rate the current tax rate is about
$85 a uh uh an employee for unemployment
they're at the all-time low well a
30-year low the fund is at a high it's
never really been this High uh 400
million would be the top end but they
have as a result of it being over $350
million they have taken advantage of
each and every uh reduction
uh that is that is in the law
so the way it works is that
250 I think it's
275 so every time that fund goes up the
the uh tax rate goes down so at this
point they have reached that level where
the tax rate is the lowest it's going to
be so this particular Amendment would
have no impact on that that uh that
level now
what this in expanding what's going on
with the system currently is that when
you and this has been going on for 20
years because there has been no increase
in the unemployment rate in 20 years so
what what happens right now is that
people making more than $41,500
uh they max out so the maximum benefit
people can receive is
$427 under the current
system now with this um and just give me
a minute so I can uh make sure I get
this
right um there will be an increase so
uh the maximum weekly benefit uh am M
New Hampshire during Kia was count 23
ATT there were 11,400 individuals paid
UI benefits and 6,500 of them or 58%
qualified or were paid to 427
uh the average base period however for
the claimants uh qualifying for 427 in
2023 was
86,5 so the base so that's important to
note because what happens as you get up
to the
415 when you start to go Beyond 415 the
replacement ratio goes down and so those
people who are making more than
415 uh uh and you in the uh uh UI people
presented this to us uh it represents
about a
26% wage replacement
rate and uh that's that's the problem
with not increasing the upper level of
it now
uh there were other uh there were other
is things that they talked about when
they went into 2024 but the trend is
continues to be basically the same
um except that the wages get higher each
year so the more they go up the the less
that that deteriorate the more that
deteriorates that replacement rate now
nationally what you try to shoot for is
somewhere in the 50 some OD percent
range and that happens to be the case as
you come from the bottom of the scale
and you go up until you hit that that
415 that's where it really shoots down
so you got you basically have this uh 50
I think it's 53 to
56% replacement rate uh towards the
middle and in the top end of the 415 but
once you hit once you go over that
threshold it really starts to
deteriorate so the question it's a
question of um of equity I think in
terms of you know do people can we
increase that so that the replacement
rate is increased uh and is that given
that the lower end of scale is getting
it getting more money uh it doesn't make
sense to to increase the top end of that
scale as
well so that essentially is is the the
nature of the of this legislation and
essentially that's what it does now
worst case scenario you could end up
with uh tax increases and things like
that that's why they test this for mild
and and severe recessions but currently
uh as I understand it there will be no
uh impact on the uh contribution rate uh
if this legislation is is passed as I
understand it from UI because the rates
have already been set all of the
discounts are in
place so that's uh that's essentially
what what the uh what the bill is Mr
chairman and representative a
thank you U Mr chairman thank you
representative McKenzie for being here
um
did Mr lers means test this for
utilization like a higher rate means
they're going to be on unemployment
longer oh wonderful oh good I will defer
well let me just say that and I'm sure
you'd like to hear from him more than
me um there is there is some evidence uh
I believe in some testimony that we
heard that when the rate went up for Co
there was some uh some increase in in
the number of weeks as I understand that
the average week a number of weeks that
people are unemployment is about 12
weeks up slightly from the last time I
looked at
it but let me say let me say and those
people that ever been unemployed
understand this uh that the unemployment
system there is no sitting around on the
when you're on
unemployment there is no you know I'm
just going to watch TV and stay home
there is a very strict uh rigid system
that requires you to be available and
looking for work all the time so you you
and if you don't do that you don't file
with the with the Department Employment
Security then you're not going to get
your benefits you be denied so it's a
very important thing to understand and
let me also say that uh while the UI
benefits are one component of uh of the
support system that surrounds a
unemployed worker
there are all of these other things that
are taking place when somebody's on
Unemployment uh you have all the
services that are available to you
training and resume writing and job
seeking and and polishing up all of the
things that uh that you need and
understand that people are not quitting
you can't quitting get on unemployment
you have to be let go uh and many times
unexpectedly so is 12 weeks reasonable I
don't know but I I don't think think
that the evidence would show that
increasing the UI benefits going to keep
people on longer this is not a u so I I
mean and Lees um commissioner Lees can
talk to that better than I
could are there any other questions
representative K thank you Mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question uh while I I might have thought
that someone making 42,000 or 2,000
would be in a better place to prepare
and and be ready for such an impact I I
and maybe have you know 30% of their
salary you know set aside I realize that
inflation has taken a a big b out of
that and it takes a lot more to make
your monthly obligations and it's also
true that people tend to live maybe a
little bit closer to what they can
actually afford rather than you know
comfortably uh so does this is it also
is it also true that there are more High
earners coming into the state I think I
read this from Mr gly that people are
generally making you know in the in the
80s it's an average or median wage and
that this is the people that you're
trying to assist uh so that they don't
uh fall short on their mortgage payments
and things of that nature well the the
according to the uh analysis that was
done by the employment security uh 427
in
2320 uh the base period for that was 8
6,359 was the base period and because of
that
427 against the 86 359 the base the wage
replacement was
26% so if you look at the economic data
would suggest that that somewhere around
58,000 is what somebody needs to live in
New Hampshire family needs you pay
insurance you pay all car and all that
kind of stuff so this gets us somewhat
closer uh to uh to to that number but
there are high earners coming into the
state uh for sure
and you know people are going to get
people can walk into work we hear this
all the time and all of a sudden they
they have no job and you is 12 weeks uh
too much uh they're entitled to 26 and
very PE few people ever get there most
people but people are back to work and I
think the system does a good job and
getting him back to work and you know
just think as you as you go through this
uh the impact on people's family when
you all of a sudden you you come in on
Monday and you go home on Tuesday and
that's it don't come
back that has a big impact on on the
stability of the family uh the stress
that causes is enormous and this I hope
uh I can appeal to you to increase the
rate to help put that stress and and
discomfort that occurs whenever anybody
is suddenly laid off thank you
any other questions so I did have a
clarification so in in in your testimony
just now I thought you said that there's
no impact on the employer in terms of
higher rates but when I look at the
analysis it says that
employers that taxes owed by employers
during 2027 will increase by 22.5
million
so can you clarify that please well I if
you would mind I defer to uh we can
defer that yeah fine minus any is at the
rate itself um because it's already set
that the rate itself will not be
impacted the the um the UI rate that
they have that's my understanding
because of where because every every one
of the discounts has already been
applied but I I think that um
clarification could be made all right
seeing no further questions sir thank
you for the work on the amend
um and for your
explanation and Mr labers if you have a
minute and if you could both fill out
pin cards so that we're straight on
testimony I appreciate that yeah I'm
sorry for being a few minutes late
to um do the members have a copy I think
I started around here copy of the
analysis of the amendment
yeah uh so uh for the record Richard
labers Deputy Commissioner New Hampshire
employment
security um so the amendment to House
Bill 542 that representative McKenzie
has introduced um in the analysis that
the department provided you can see what
he's what he's uh um um suggesting now
to do is rather than 12 additional tiers
it would be six additional tiers so the
maximum uh benefit uh would be uh under
his proposal
um would be
$535 a week for someone that had earned
at least $52,000 in their four quarter
base period compared to the current
maximum of
427 uh which someone who earns $41,500
in their base period uh would need to
earn um his proposed new maximum
maintains the same wage replacement rate
as in the current schedule of Ben
benefits um it's
53.5% wage replacement meaning it's
replacing just over half of the dollars
you earned an employment with your
unemployment
benefit um I did excuse me I did um
update the analysis to show that in the
actual filers what their wage
replacement rate has been so in
2024 um the individuals that qualified
for our current maximum benefit of
$427 their average base period earnings
was just over
$88,500
so they had a an actual wage replacement
rate of about
25% uh when we look at the average
private sector worker right now in New
Hampshire um when I look at the the data
that we have available is for the first
half of 2024 this is from the
administrative records filed by
employers U this the this bill um at the
maximum weekly benefit amount of 535
would be a wage replacement rate of
about
35% to that average private sector
worker uh with regard to so that's the
impact on the individual filers and I
did include information showing how many
individuals from 2020 before would have
seen an increase in their weekly benefit
if this bill uh were in effect um
shifting gears for the impact on
employers uh we did update that analysis
so you can see uh what the impact would
be under current economic conditions as
well as applying this to the model that
mimicked a mild recession as well as a
model that mimicked a severe um U or
major recession I believe is how we
refer to it in the current economic
conditions there would not be any impact
to the fund balance reductions or the
discounts that employers have on their
earned tax rate right now employers get
a 1% reduction to their rate because the
fund balance uh exceeds $350
million that that is what is currently
forecast without any changes the fund
will continue to maintain a balance
north of
350 but will not hit the $400 million
threshold which would trigger the
maximum fund balance reduction or
discount of
1.5% so right now without any changes to
the benefit schedule we are not
forecasting employers to get to that 1
and a half% reduction we're forecasting
the 1% reduction The Proposal from
representative McKenzie as amended would
not impact the fund performance in terms
of that fund balance reduction that
employers um are forecasted to
experience again that's with current
economic conditions no economic
downturn um when we looked at the um
mild and the major recessionary
scenarios again a lot of assumptions
that are made here um The Economist do
uh try to uh caveat these by reminding
me that the further you get out from
your current date the less um uh
confidence they have in the accuracy um
of those forecasts but when you look at
both recessionary scenarios The Proposal
from representative McKenzie in his
Amendment would cause an impact on
employers where they would lose the
forecasted fund balance reduction a
quarter sooner than they would without
making these changes to the benefit
schedule uh so you're looking out uh to
the first quarter of 2027 in order for
that uh forecasted impact to hit uh but
without any change in those recessionary
scenarios we would forecast employers to
still have a half Point reduction in the
first quarter of
27 with the ended benefit schedule from
representative McKenzie we forecast that
the employers would not have that half
Point fund balance reduction in the
first quarter of 27 uh so it's with the
impact of not having that half Point
reduction in the first quarter of 27
that causes a forecasted increase in
taxes paid for that quarter of just
under $23 million so to recap that
current economic conditions we do not
forecast this proposal to have any
impact on the fund balance reductions in
both recessionary forecasts we do impact
do forecast there to be an impact on
Employers in the tax rate at which
they're going to be paying to support
the unemployment program and I can stop
right there Mr chairman and if there are
any questions I can take them now thank
you for the explanation are there any
questions representative Flanigan thank
you Mr Shar it's good to see you again
Mr L uh and thank you for your testimony
um it's sort of bented around that the
longer you have the ability to
collect it's a propensity to stay
unemployed is there any studies out
there or is there any research that you
know of that can say that if if the
duration longer that tend people tend to
be on unemployment
longer yes so it's it's a good question
um what I can tell you is so with this
proposal is simply proposing to increase
the amount and not the increase the
duration for which you can file um when
we look at our current duration New
Hampshire does quite well um both um
when we look at average duration of
being uh just over 12 weeks and also our
exhaustion rate being uh I believe we
right around 16% exhaustion um so right
now you're eligible for up to 26 weeks
okay average duration is just over 12 it
has been increasing slightly since the
beginning of 23 I had noted in previous
testimony I will say and we get this
data monthly I will say that the
December to January um average duration
didn't change um it actually stayed
right where it was um that could be a a
sign of a leveling off I don't know um
but right now you just over 12 weeks
despite having eligibility for 26 so
people are going back to work quickly
they're going back to work sooner than
most um individuals filing for
unemployment in other states uh our
average duration is the 11th lowest in
the country and our exhaustion rate of
uh
15% um is uh the second lowest in the
Northeast and second lowest EX austion
rate in the country Vermont's at
15% um I will point out states that do
have fewer weeks and 26 weeks is the the
dominant um number of weeks available in
unemployment programs um in States
across the country US Department of
Labor you you can adjust your weeks that
you have available they are not going to
cry foul and suggest that that is
somehow uh a violation of Conformity or
compliance with Federal standards U but
states that do have few fewer weeks uh
they tend to have very high exhaustion
rates uh so um Florida being one of them
I believe Florida has 13 weeks available
um more than half of their filers
exhaust the weeks that they have
available um so I I
think in my in my opinion and my
experience with the Department is having
more weeks available than you use so
right now we're only using less than
half of what is available but having
those available so you have the
flexibility to adjust with economic
conditions and the needs of your
Workforce that um could find themselves
needing to file for unemployment right
now um there are uh the the jobs that
are available continue to be uh fairly
plentiful um so your ability to find new
Employments um is definitely a weight on
the on the side of the worker if we were
to get into to a different uh set of
economic conditions jobs are more
difficult to find um and your duration
goes up uh I think most people would be
um pleased that they had the
flexibility with the current structure
of the program to um provide some level
of wage replacement for people in those
uh situations where you have fewer jobs
available and it's harder to find
employment um I know um certainly the
the pandemic was an outlier um in terms
of the ability to return to work uh but
the ability to continue to file and have
some wage replacement was certainly um a
godsend for a lot of individuals a lot
of workers in the state during that
period and and was certainly um um
helpful for families and individuals
during the Great Recession as well
follow up thank you and for followup
representative FL thank you uh very
brief although I'm not sure if it can be
answered briefly but um if we do in fact
make this change that is allow for a
higher
income um and all of a sudden we have
some catastrophic economic events it's
very unlikely that we can go back isn't
that
true um in terms of uh reducing the
weekly benefit amount
um it would be highly unlikely to reduce
the weekly benefit uh amounts at that
point because um I can tell you which
direction inflation is going to continue
to go
yeah thank you very much thank you Mr
represent
Granger I'll
pass did you have
a got it and representative
kale thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
lers uh so if if this amendment were to
pass I understand we' be going from a
uh 26% wage replacement to a 35% wage
replacement for uh the average uh the 80
was that the 86,000 uh
earner that was um and sorry that that
was somewhat confusing so the
35% is looking at the average private
sector worker the other the which would
be a 35% wage replacement the other
statistic I cited was for the
individuals that filed for unemployment
benefits during
2024 their average base period earnings
during that four quarter period was
88,500 so their wage their actual wage
replacement with the current benefit
structure was about
26% but when we look at the entire
private sector Workforce that average
private sector worker it'd be about a
35% under what is being proposed by
representative McKenzie follow up yes
sir thank you so it it would seem to me
unlikely that someone would
lollygag uh with that difference in in
uh payments they would still be needing
to make closer to their normal earnings
in the event of her layoff and they
haven't found a suitable replacement
position even with this uh increase is
that
correct um we do work um uh all of our
staff throughout all of the New
Hampshire Works offices work hard uh
with individuals help helping them find
employment and individuals do have uh
requirements on their weekly claim where
they have to document their efforts to
make themselves available for work uh
they have to show that they're able to
work and they have to demonstrate that
they are actively searching for work so
um without any change to any of those
requirements individuals would still be
required to contact employers be still
required to make that effort and
certainly a wage replacement rate that
that is providing you with less than
half of what you were earning uh
provides uh some extra motivation as
well thank you and repres stop thank you
Mr
chairman um as I'm looking at the um
impacts of the mild recession and the
major
recession um it says that at the end of
2027 there would be an impact on the
amount that employers had to pay um can
you describe when that recession when
you're predicting that that recession
would start I mean is it 2025 2026 and
then at the end of 2027 so you know two
and a half years or three years or two
years um so just to be clear we we are
not forecasting there to be a
recession um let me say that again New
Hampshire employment security and the
economic and labor market information
Bureau is not forecasting there to be a
recession um but when we apply the
stress testing to the trust fund to see
how the trust fund would perform under a
different benefit schedule that's what
you were seeing there so hypotheticals
not what we are forecasting um our start
our starting uh quarter for each of
those hypothetical situations was the
third quarter of this year third
calendar quarter assuming that if this
bill were to pass um that would be the
quarter that you would uh see the impact
uh would start me ask a followup yes
ma'am thank you
um so if in that case um we've said that
um um you've said that the average
amount that employers are paying in per
employee is $85 and at the end of 20 27
there would be more um they would need
to be contributing more do you have you
done the math to figure out what um what
the average cost per employee would be I
kind of did
some so the so the average right now
you're correct um the average employers
paying at 61% so they pay that on the
first $14,000 in annual earnings to each
employee for $85 per year right now um
so the impact there that you're seeing
in both recessionary scenarios is the
employers would be for be projected
again a lot of assumptions made here um
but they would be projected to lose the
half Point fund balance reduction so if
you were still um at that average 61 or
actually you wouldn't be at the average
let's make this even more complicated um
um you would have already lost a half
point because right now they got a full
point reduction on their rate right
that's what they currently experience um
when you go that deep into the recession
they would have already lost that full
point and they would be at the half
point so that average employer at 61
would be um at
1.1 um and so by not having that half
Point reduction in that first quarter of
27 they would actually be at a point and
a half
1.5%
1.6% would be what they would be paying
on the first
$144,000 um in annual earnings for each
employee comp compared to 1.1 versus is
1.6 and when you when you um um
calculate the impact the total impact on
employers Statewide that's where you get
the figure of
$22.9 million collectively amongst all
employers by not having that half Point
discount in that
quarter that's clear thank you and
representative Roy or Hall I'm sorry
that works fine thank uh thanks for uh
thank thanks for testifying um as I look
at this table um a question comes up I
it seems to run from the benefits run
from 1.14% to
1.02 but is there an advantage to having
it structured this way versus just
having in the statute a straight
percentage does this make the
Department's job easier does it you know
is it saving money somehow I mean would
it be better and save the taxpayers
money overall would it reduce your costs
if we just had in the statute a straight
percentage um
so New Hampshire has always done it this
way um with the the benefit table that
you see um Can the department do it a
different way we certainly can't um
there would be uh money and time uh
needed to do that to reprogram the
current system to calculate that weekly
benefit amount differently if we were to
calculate it based off of not the the uh
earning tiers that you see but as a
straight replacement rate for what you
actually earned during that four quarter
base period um you'd obviously want to
put in some sort of uh maximum at which
you're going to provide that wage
replacement I think we've talked before
about how social security has a wage cap
uh that they no longer um tax those
earnings above I think it's in the mid
140s um is how Social Security applies
that most short-term disability programs
New Hampshire's Paid Family Leave
program they they do it the same way
where they cap the uh wage replacement
um at that same level um it would um at
least based on our current claim filing
population with the some of the numbers
I provided with those people that uh um
qualified for the maximum right now 427
those that qualified in 2024 their
average base period earnings was over
$888,000 over $88,500
actually um so there would be a higher
benefit cost um depending on what you
set your wage replacement rate at um but
uh to do a um um you know to keep a a
50% 54% like the current um goal um at
the uh 415 which is not what happens in
reality because people are earning 885
um but to set a a 50% wage replacement
there would be a significant increase in
the amount of benefits being
paid okay representive km thank you
again Mr chair and thank you again Mr
labers so uh when the uh fund balance
reaches a certain level like when when a
bell rings the angel gets its
wings um so that affects Statewide all
the employers regardless so their
history get a little bit of something or
a little bit more of a benefit but uh
how does that come down to the the 22
million to the individual average
employer right now at 85 uh if we pass
this would it go to 8550 or $86 annually
could you tell us that today
um the quick math my father was my high
school calculus teacher okay he's
probably looking down and wondering how
well his lawyer son is going to do um
but um you'd be looking at so instead of
paying at that again to be Apples to
Apples for that particular quarter um
without any change employers would be
paying at 1.1% on the first 14,000 with
this proposed change they'd be paying at
1.6% on the first
14,000 uh so
um I can do that math off of uh
when I'm out of the spotlight I do see a
few of your colleagues that are doing
the math right now so um it's um a sign
it's more than double of probably more
than double of what they're paying at 85
right now but 85 is not what they'd be
paying in that scenario anyway um 85 is
only what they're what they're paying
right now per employee at 61% is the
average employer but the Apples to
Apples would be to compare 1.1% versus
1.6% well please and and again this is
is only on the first 14,000 we're not
adjusting that to uh 25,000 or anything
crazy correct it's that that uh um that
rate the amount of earnings would be
there's no um uh um request in this
proposal uh from representative McKenzie
to change that um and the reason why the
impact being as high as it is that $22.9
million is because as we've talked about
um employers that don't have seasonal
patterns to their employment most of
their unemployment tax is paid as a
result of earnings in that first quarter
and it's that first quarter that this
proposal would be uh projected to impact
in 2027 thank you very much good good
question represent
avalani thank you Mr chairman thank you
Deputy Commissioner labors um
utilization typically when the benefits
of higher people will stay on
unemployment longer um did you means
test any of that in here with under the
new
Amendment so so it's a it's a good
question um as um elme Economist Brian
golob has pointed out before the
existence of an unemployment program
increases duration increases the
duration of unemployment um but that's
why it exists right it's to provide that
support rather than fall off a clip and
try to dig your way out uh to to
hopefully find a job on the other side
um what these um stress test scenarios
did so the answer is yes um because they
they they mimicked as best they could
claim filing behaviors from those two
recessionary scenarios so we we
obviously started from the current size
of the labor force rather than the the
prior um configurations of the labor
force but so we took our current labor
force and we applied that 2001 mild
recession um unemployment going from
right now 2 uh 6% going up to 4 and a
half% um the same patterns with duration
that were experienced in that mild
relatively short economic downturn of
2001 are what were applied there in the
mild recession and then the major
recession um we applied the the um Great
Recession scenario so um 6 and a half%
Unemployment uh uh duration um went um a
significant increase I believe you were
probably in the average duration of
probably 18 weeks um in that time period
so again we borrowed the behavior years
from that time period uh to apply to the
um worst case we hope worst case um
stress test
scenario thank you uh followup Mr
chairman yes sir thank you um the fund
triggers um I know you mentioned them in
here so it's actually a two-part
question when the fund triggers a
reduction or an increase in the taxes
are we also going to see some positive
rated employers now fall into being
negatively rated because of additional
the additional expense of utilization
and the additional length of time that
people will be on it and would they now
be not subject
to that credit because of the fund
balance so the um impact on the fund
balance
reductions that would not cause an
employer to go from positive rated to
negative rated right the calculation
that could be imp Ed would be um every
year um in August we send out our annual
tax rate
redetermination and in that we provide
the employer with all of their
experience in the entire history of them
being an employer in the state of New
Hampshire we
recalculate their entire amount of taxes
paid their entire amount of the benefits
we've paid out to their former employees
so they were the last employing unit
which uh led to someone um being
unemployed and eligible for unemployment
benefits but we look at all of that and
we compare it against their current most
recent total wages paid and that's what
determines whether they're going to be
in that um lowest wage uh lowest tax
schedule for the positive rated um and
then if you're newly negative you go in
that mid schedule and then you're
chronically negative long-term negative
over four years you're you're in that
highest wage schedule so if you are
right on the uh you know you're you're
balanced on the edge of a knife right
with being positive rated an increase to
the amount of benefits going out could
hypothetically could cause you to go
negatively rated um you'd be in that
second schedule because you'd be you
know you'd be a newly negative rated
employer um but again if you're if
you're right on the cusp of having the
amount of benefits paid uh being more
than the amount of taxes you have paid
um then that could cause you to move to
that negative rated schedule but if you
haven't had um a a high amount of layoff
activity um you've been paying your
taxes timely and you're um comfortably
within that positive R category then it
wouldn't cause that but if if someone's
right on the edge um yes and an increase
in benefits could cause them to go to
that higher schedule thank you thank you
Mr
chairman thank you for the question
representative K thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr lers um in your experience
with on the topic of
utilization what's the larger factor is
it the benefit amount or the skills uh
and age and availability you of
replacement
jobs uh the the biggest the the biggest
Factor
um that influences duration is a current
state of the
economy um right now duration is low um
I'd like to say it's because of the
people that work for the Department
doing such a great job of getting people
back to work um but duration is low
because of the economy it's because New
Hampshire continues to have a strong
economy stronger labor force growth than
any other state in the entire Northeast
exceeding labor force growth of the
entire country for the second half of 24
um that is what leads to individuals
quickly finding employment um because no
one wants to be unemployment for longer
than they have to be um and that's why
no one is here talking about 100% wage
replacement um so there needs to always
uh be uh an effort to strike that
balance of a wage replacement that can
continue to allow you to provide for
your family but encourage you to find
that new employment opportunity
hopefully comparable or better than what
you had before as quickly as possible
but it's always um in my experience the
economic conditions um that influence
that duration um um unless you go to an
extreme like Massachusetts um and you're
going to have uh wage replacement rates
that are incredibly High um and even
right now um you know New Hampshire
we're at 12 weeks average duration
Massachusetts is Massachusetts right now
is at New Hampshire's recessionary
duration um they're over 18 weeks so
that's kind of an example of when you um
uh uh strike uh too far on the other
side and are providing too much of a
wage replacement rate and they don't and
their their trust fund is insolvent so
thank you res Schultz thank you Mr chair
um to follow up on that conversation I'm
wondering to what degree uh does an
unemployed person find a job comparable
and pay at that higher end of wages are
do they find are they relegated to
crappier wages for lack of a better
term um
so what we use to gauge um whether or
not the job that you are offered is
suitable we look at a lot of factors so
you can take whatever job you want right
um in order to continue to be eligible
for unemployment benefits you can't
reject an offer of suitable employment
and for suitable employment we look at
what you were earning before we look at
what the proposed earnings are with the
job that you were offered we look at a
whole host of other factors as well um
is it the same shift that you were
previously working um what are your
reasons for not being able to
potentially take this shift you know are
there family responsibilities um what's
the commuting distance what is the um
job itself how does it compare to what
you previously did so we look at all of
that and it's not just because you Deni
you turn down a job offer that we're
automatically going to say that you
you're no longer eligible for
unemployment we need to make sure that
is suitable um but an individual can
accept whatever job that they want um
and stop filing obviously if you're um
working only part-time you could
continue to file New Hampshire allows
part-time workers
uh to continue to file for unemployment
but that's how we um look at those
situations if you if you refuse a job
offer we we do the um our our staff are
skilled on looking at whether or not an
offer was suitable or
not for a
followup thank you Mr chair um you
didn't really answer my question but
everything you said was informative and
I appreciated that because I learned a
few things um so say someone is going on
um unemployment in the average economy
maybe it's a little a little bit of a
recession but you know whatever um and
they are making say 880,000 uh a year on
the white color job I'd heard that um
the New
Hampshire has a good job market but not
for the $80,000 white collar job
necessarily that's really my question so
if someone's unemployed they've been
laid off or you know their business
shuts down whatever um are they so in
addition to comparable uh suitable
replacement do you maybe you just don't
know the statistic to what degree are
people able to find you know similar
enough wages in their next job after a
period of
unemployment um and so I would just look
uh point you back to the average
duration right now uh where um
individuals are filing for um just over
12 weeks despite having 26 available the
average private sector earnings
continues to go up um all of those are
indicators that um uh people are not
just feeling they need to take whatever
job is offered to them um people uh you
know they're they're quickly able to
find uh what they believe um in their
situation is suitable and I would assume
be comparable to what they were were
previously
earning and represent stop thank you Mr
chairman
um there are some Industries in the
state Advanced manufacturing Etc that
are always saying well we have plenty of
job openings but the jobs are very
specialized and so there are shortages
in those Industries so I guess my
question to you
is are those people those people tend to
be at the higher end of the scale who
are only getting like if they lose that
job they get like a 25% replacement and
it may be a while before another job
opening comes in that field um
are we likely to lose that person to
another state and then continue to have
this shortage in our own state of you
know highly skilled specialized um
workers um so New Hampshire hasn't
experienced an increase in the number of
of residents that are are working
outside of New Hampshire um you know it
continues to be what it was prior to the
pandemic um with some um slight change
with the number of people that are
working remote obviously ly is that has
increased uh since the pandemic um but
you have about 120,000 New Hampshire
residents that commute out of state uh
to work um and we get about 880,000
people that commute into the state uh to
work um what we do for those individuals
that um um are looking to gain the
skills in a particular high demand
occupation uh we have several different
training programs that can provide uh
financial support and one-on-one case
management with an employment counselor
we connect them with the uh training
institutions most instances that's going
to be one of our community college
system campuses um but we connect them
with the training opportunities in most
instances if you're uh a dislocated
worker um you're going to be able to get
that training paid for um not out of
your own pocket you're going to get it
uh paid for pour out of the um Workforce
Innovation Opportunity Act dollars that
uh come in from the federal government
um but we also have other training
programs for individuals coming off that
are on Medicaid snap tanif we pay for
their training as well we try to
encourage them into high demand
occupations particularly in those
sectors that we know offer good solid
career trajectory and the and the state
has a critical need for like healthcare
individuals don't always make those
choices um as uh but we try to encourage
them into those fields but there's a lot
of uh programs that pay for that
training all right sir I hope I
appreciate all the work you did to
clarify this and for your testimony
thank you so much thank
you are there any other pin cards anyone
else uh have anything regarding
testimony okay great seeing none I
closed the hearing on H B
542 and uh we'll take a break for about
5 minutes and then we'll open the
hearing on HB 744 thank
you
e
e e
Mr
labers Mr labers left no he's right
there is he can you give me a pink C
please oh you're awesome great thank you
sir
e
e e
don't don't hurt yourself represent
K I'd like to open the H open the uh
reopen the hearing on HP
744 and uh much like the HP 542 is that
we we had a great discussion on 744 but
there were some things that needed to be
worked on it and uh representive
McKenzie's done a lot of good work um to
get at some of those issues and so we
like to hear about that I'm just going
to state that I have to step out at
11:30 and representative avalani will uh
assume the the chairmanship while I'm
gone um but representative McKenzie can
you sort of recap on where we're at and
then uh describe your Amendment and uh
before we move forward thank you sure
thank you Mr chairman my name is Mark
McKenzie at Hillsboro District
40 and I'm here to present the amendment
to House Bill
FN so the original uh legislation uh was
focused on one section of the law and in
consultation with the Department of
Labor it was brought to my attention
that there were other sections of the
law that were affected and therefore
they they asked uh to to forward an
amendment which would take into
consideration all the areas of the law
um that were affected I I ran this by
them uh They said that the corrections
had been made and that the uh change is
consistent throughout the
law and that is essentially what the
amendment uh that that was restructuring
the amendment now it doesn't change the
initial um proposal which is to move the
rate from 60% to 66 and
23% for those areas of the law uh that
involve the emity
benefits and if I could Mr chairman uh I
would like to just uh give a very
brief um uh presentation relative to put
this in
context uh and I think I sent you some
of this uh some of this
stuff this uh this uh period reform
period I would say began sometime in the
uh in the early
90s uh and it was uh the Catalyst for it
was a a proposed increase of 37% in the
unemployment rate in the uh workers
compensation rate
it caused a um a series of uh reform
study committees it was one uh that took
place in the 90 and then
93 so you did one under Governor
um uh Greg one under Governor Merill and
one under Governor
Lynch the two first ones were probably
the most
um were probably the most impactful on
the system Governor Lynch didn't uh his
commission didn't report out much I was
actually on it um and
so what we what we ended up with was
this series of reforms and this was one
of those reforms that took place under
house bill
1409 now also included uh uh at the time
was
uh was a a ser series of things which
were were done to affect the overall
rate give you an example without going
too far into the
weeds um they adopted things like uh AMA
uh schedules for Disabilities the whole
idea of of work as compensation is to
try to uh to to try to insulate I mean
when you're looking at pricing it the
commissioner the insurance department is
there but you want to limit risk
um and I say that in the sense that uh
there is this balance that you try to
achieve in the law you try to achieve uh
get to a place where the benefits are
sufficient because the law uh is a
tradeoff workers's compensation
represents a trade-off between the
employer and the worker and the idea is
that the worker uh loses for the most
part except in some really unreasonable
cases the ability to sue the employer
and the Qui quo is that there is this
system of benefits and so over the
course of these reforms they chipped
away at the benefits uh to get the cost
what they think said is a cost in line
and it and if you heard recently that it
has resulted over a period of some 20
years in reducing uh the cost of uh UI
now I cost of work as comp
uh but I would suggest that those those
were uh the the the industry has
recovered uh there were representatives
from the industry that here to suggest
that the industry is in good shape is a
good line of business so this is one of
one of the many
things um that I think need some
attention and
essentially what this will do is to
restore that uh that piece of the law
that was reduced to 60% under house bill
1409 now pretty much around the country
the rate for the replacement rate for
the indemnity side of the of the agenda
is is 66 and 23 essentially uh
throughout the country I don't know if
it's in every state uh that's what we
heard I'm not sure it's in every state
but that's a that uh would take some
research on on my part to figure if
that's actually accurate but the
majority of states will say pay 66 and
2/3
now I I think there's a lot of
justification for restoring this you
know at the same time they were reducing
this they were also rolling back things
in terms of the length of time you could
be on
disability so at one point you could be
on disability for 350 weeks at the same
almost in the same page that they were
taking the 60% they were cutting that
back to 262 weeks so these are the kinds
of things that were happening and we got
caught up in it and I think by the
testimony that we've heard is that the
industry has recovered there were
hundred I think it was testimony there
were 100 people doing workers
compensation in the state offering it in
the early 90s there was one and that
particular company was going to pull out
and this was not only the case here it
was the case in Maine it was the case in
other places in this country
so something needed to be done and
something was done now you might some
people might say well well that was a
deal and you know things don't change
well in fact things have changed uh one
of the cornerstones of this for workers
was to keep in place uh the safety and
health plans so part of our demand when
we were going through this was that we
wanted programs that would make the
workplaces safer and they did that and I
think the evidence will show the dity
benefits are about 40% of the cost as
opposed to 60% of the uh o of the the
cost of insurance so we have done a
pretty good job of making workplace
safer which is an upside of of this but
there have been changes to that for
instance when we originally negotiated
this it were uh you needed U it was 10
employees I believe that you need a
safety plan you had to file it each year
I think it's up to 15 now and you don't
have to file it each year anymore so
that was a big change uh that they made
they made some other changes uh also uh
in a while they dealt with
things uh around safety committees in
general um so they have made changes in
this but not none of the things that
really impact the the cost of the
program this will impact the cost of the
program uh I you have some analysis that
was done by The ncci Who is the agency
that ENT
does a
rating uh for the uh for the system and
they show and I think the insurance
department indicated this kind of off
the cuff and I think it's we're right in
line it's it's between five uh and
6.3% increase in the in the work in the
workers compensation rate I also uh was
given some information from the ncci
which
I um V loss cost filing history is a
little out of my
wheelhouse but I think if I get this
right if I understand this is is there
has uh been a series of
decreases uh and the insurance company
can re and if I'm misstating this I'm
sure I'll be corrected but there seems
to be a trend where the where the where
the actual cost of the insurance has
been has been going down it's it's
varied over a period of years is from 19
to 2025 from a high
of-4 to a low of uh I think 1.8 back in
2021 projection is minus
5.6 so if I get that right it looks like
it's been
trending um it's we're in a position
where uh where there have been some
decreases but again I may not have that
correct and I hope somebody would would
correct that if I'm misstating it so Mr
chairman I think the the this this
simply restor of benefit uh I could
spend three days talking about the
workers comp reform um but I think it's
given that there are 100 people offering
this today that the system has recovered
that there's some room to go back and
restore some of the stuff that occurred
over the course of the years and uh I in
this this particular piece has been as
representative aino knows this has been
in front of this committee on more than
one occasion
uh but I think we have pretty good
evidence now that this makes sense to
restore
it okay thank you for your your work and
clarifying that and updating the bill as
as amended are there any questions
representative K thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question um so I I've noticed that in
the amendment we are not going
retroactive which would be very
complicated we are merely going forward
from the after the acct is that correct
that's correct that was uh that was
something that we need to clarify from
the last hearing we did so so this will
be only for injuries that occurred uh on
or after January 1st of uh 2026 thank
you okay good question any other
questions repres clar thank you is it
true that most of the states in the
country have the 66 and 2/3 that's
that's mine standing and I think there
was testimony from the insurance
Department relative to that as
well okay Roger thank
you okay seeing no further questions sir
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for your
update and uh can I have Mr Fantasy
please please uh state your name and who
you represent for the record thank you
Nathan fennessy uh I'm an attorney at
pretty flarity here in conquer I
represent ncci good to see most of you
uh back again uh I did bring hard copies
I sent out to the committee the analysis
that ncci performed if you could just
hand those to both sides so we can send
them around please thank you
so I won't go through all of the
analysis but I I did want to just
highlight a couple of things I'm sure
you've had an opportunity to review it
at this point um ncci after doing the
calculations uh and as I understand it
uh the amendment uh reflects what was
discussed at the last public hearing
which is what we uh base the analysis on
uh as representative mckenny McKenzie
sorry uh said the estimate is that the
if an acted it would result in an impact
of between 5% and 6.3% increase on
overall workers comp system costs in New
Hampshire um that's based on the private
Market um we did include a footnote uh
it's footnote one at the bottom of page
one so
uh the 5% to 6.3% is based upon our
calculations that based on the private
Market there be an increase between 12
million and 15 million in overall
workers comp system
costs uh we don't get data about
self-insured but uh there's an
organization called uh the National
Academy of social
insurance which has some data uh we
don't know what it is but they have
certain information about self-insurers
in New Hampshire and based on their data
we did make an estimate that if you
include what they uh consider to be the
uh self-insured Market in New Hampshire
that uh the range would be between 17
million and 22 million so you know
approximately five uh to um to uh 7
million more as far as overall workers
comp system costs and that's a ass uming
we use the same percentage that the the
same percentage would apply to those in
the self-insured
market one thing I I did want to
highlight and this came up at the last
public hearing so there are different
types of benefits uh so the calculations
are slightly different um based upon one
of the one of the factors that we
considered was utilization uh NCC has
done analysis in the past that shows
that if you increase the indemnity
benefit there's an increase in
utilization which basically means people
may stay on the benefit longer so uh for
purposes of the
calculation uh we used uh different
utilization factors based on different
benefits so uh if you look at the chart
on uh page
three uh we broke out the essentially
the four different types of benefits
that there are and then uh showed the uh
the share of the indemnity losses
overall in the system so for example the
Fatal injury type makes up about 4.8% of
the overall uh emity losses in New
Hampshire uh we then uh performed a
calculation so the analysis was
essentially that this increase from 60
to um 6 and 2/3 was approximately
um uh
97% in direct Indemnity cost going so in
the in the Fatal category uh that works
out to 99.4% there's no change to
utilization we didn't because you know
if you die you're not going to use it
anymore uh but then we did going down to
uh uh permanent total
disability uh that's only 1.3% and then
we have estimates of again there's no
change to the the utilization because if
it's permanent total disability
nothing's going to change the really
change is going to happen with the two
categories of uh permanent partial and
uh total um total temporary disability
or um total
uh I'm blanking on the other one but we
calculate them the same the
total uh partial disability because it's
calculated the same way uh and we use
slightly different utilization factors
based on the analysis that ncci has done
in the past to come up with the the
lower bound and the upper bound
estimates which are reflected there uh
again you're looking at uh 41.9% is the
permanent partial disability category uh
and 52% is the temporary total dis
ability piece uh we then if you uh
multiply those all together and uh you
then come up with a lower bound estimate
of 12.2% to
15.3% uh but then you have to uh uh
divide by uh 41% because only uh 41% of
the overall system uh cost is associated
with the indemnity benefit which gives
the 5% to 6.3% range that we
provided if anybody wants to uh ask any
questions I'm happy to take them yeah so
first of all I appreciate you turning
this around as you said you would by
last Friday thank you and for sending
that out to everyone just just from my
own clarification who pays these costs
this five to six
6.3% who's whose pocket does that come
from so the five to 6.3% the assumption
is that's
overall uh system costs now in the
private system the assumption would be
that uh at least some if not all of that
would be picked up through an increase
in
premium okay so that's a premium PID by
the the employer by the employer correct
okay and any other
questions represent Clair yeah thank you
so the utilization part doesn't a doctor
typically let a person on work on work
as comp know how long they should be out
and you know when they could go back to
work obviously depending on the type of
job they have but doesn't yeah doesn't a
doctor more tell them how long they
should be out more than a person saying
I'm going to be out for 10 weeks a
doctor might say no six does that really
how it works yeah I I would say that is
generally true however um and CCI has
done analysis over time and and when
there's been changes in Indemnity
benefits they've seen in the
categories uh that are either permanent
partial or uh temporary total there
tends to be a slight increase in uh
utilization for uh individuals so um
whereas before maybe they were um on uh
workers comp for you know 20 weeks
incrementally it may go up to 21 or 22
weeks and so that that's uh based on
those observations and calculations that
ncci has done in the past uh in pricing
this we made the assumption that that
would hold true with a similar type of
uh increase
here for followup sir yeah thank
you but so are you saying that they're
going against what their position might
tell them I I don't know I I don't know
what the conversations might be between
an individual worker and their doctor
doctor uh I can just tell you that based
on what ncci's done in the past with
information that they've had they've
observed this phenomenon where uh
Injured Workers uh when there's a rate
increase may stay on the benefit
slightly
longer all right thanks okay K thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh so workers comp uh a bit
like uh unemployment insurance is is not
universally the same rate if you have if
you're a roofing company your rates are
probably a little higher than if you had
a coffee shop so it's so the rate
increase isn't spread across the whole
uh State of New Hampshire all the
employers it's going to be effective by
the type of business they have is that
correct and their experience that's
correct so I I'll give you sort of the
very basic you have uh a classification
code so uh if you have a roofing company
the classification code likely uh is uh
I'll call it the the rate is higher than
clerical uh but then you also have an
experience rating modification so you
the individual company could have a
different uh higher or lower based on
how many claims that you have had in the
past as your company itself so I I I
like to think about there's sort of two
separate aspects to uh coming up with
that follow up please thank you so so
then the employer you know acting in
their best interest and the interest
your employees will in Institute the the
best more robust uh safety program
encourage the roofers to have the the
harness and and all those things not
take any shortcuts to uh
right I would say that there is a
financial benefit if you are
experiencing claims losses and your
experience rating modification goes up
there is a financial incentive for you
to take uh safety precautions to drive
that number down in the future thank you
represent King thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um I
had a question looking at your
statistics here would the um specific
businesses that have a higher rate of
let's say code right now would they see
a larger impact from this do you
think
uh I don't know I don't know it would
depend on sort of how it played out
across the different classification
codes um I I I don't know that sitting
right right
here representative avalani thank you Mr
chairman I have a few questions um
you talked about
utilization um some Industries have
longer utilization than
others um you figure you know a more of
an office setting is going to be back to
work quicker than somebody that's broken
their leg falling off a
ladder um how does that square
with
the impact overall
for getting back to work without
extending the utilization because you're
getting paid more to stay home while
you're
injured so I would say the numbers that
we used there were just sort of we used
a range uh for each of those categories
so uh while it may be true that um that
someone who suffers a more severe injury
would be on uh the benefit for longer uh
we didn't really get into the
particulars of how it would impact one
uh classification code versus another
classific ification code thank you
follow up Mr chairman for followup uh
right now the payment system has
41% for wage replacement or Indemnity
payments um with increased utilization
will would require a change in that and
given that some in insurance people have
a very small margin given higher
healthier costs administrative
costs uh independent doctor costs
utilization claims
how does that translate into just a 5%
increase in
possible um private insurance going up
so uh I mean based on the analysis that
we did which uh factors in um
essentially what the impact to Indemnity
would be
um our analysis that was that the range
would be between five and
6.3% now over time uh the the 41%
obviously could increase in the future
we don't know if that's going to be true
or not but it could go up from 41% to
some other uh higher portion of the
overall benefit because if you're
increasing the indemnity presumably it
would go it would go above 41% at some
point um but I will say over the
last probably five to six years the
indemnity so of the gross amount of
Indemnity has generally remained about
the same um and the the rate decreases
that we have seen have been dra have
been derived almost uh exclusively
through an a an incre or decrease in
frequency of medical claims and then the
severity of the claims generally has
gone down over time which means that the
medical portion of the benefits gone
down
on on sort of on a on a gross
level oh if I can just uh because I know
represent McKenzie uh raised what I
provided to him was uh a slide that we
provided to the insurance department
with our rate filing for
2025 which showed I have a copy of it
with me right here it basically showed
what the history of the loss CA filings
have been since uh
2019 and the loss cost filing is
essentially the I'll call it the the
rate uh that ncci is filing for purposes
of the voluntary Market this is
different than the assigned risk pool uh
but generally speaking with the
exception of um well actually it's gone
down every single year since 2019 so
that's year-over-year
um in 2021 the filing was for a 1.8 uh
percent decrease which um was the lowest
decrease uh but uh the filing we made
which was approved by the department uh
this fall for starting on January 1
2025 Was A 5.6 5.6 decrease from the
year
prior I hope that answered the question
and for a followup sure um so we talked
about
the voluntary Market but there's also an
involuntary Market which is your
assigned risk correct did you look at
that in relations to this 5 to 6% or is
that going to be a different hold that's
a whole different ballpark with my
understanding is that was part of the
analysis that was done uh because
because we we do that filing on behalf
of the assigned risk pool in New
Hampshire so my understanding is that
that's part of this
analysis thank you I'll save my next
questions for the insurance commissioner
all right good represent K sir thank you
Mr chair and thank you again and um I'm
not really a math wizard but I'm not
either oh my God U maybe someone else in
earshot but I was looking at the we
talked about 86,000 annual salary that
is somewhat common in New Hampshire
though not in this room um and I just
sort of ran you know 60% times that it
was like $992 a week and I think it was
a you know with the 66 and 23 it was
another $110
is that sound close to anyone's uh math
Wizardry $110 more a week that they
would get would they would they utilize
it much longer for $110 a week I I I
can't speak to the math uh because I'm
I'm not good at math uh in front of a
crowd uh so I I can't speak to uh the
motivations individuals might have I
would say that it uh if you look at the
benefits it's not strictly 60% and 66
and 23 there's an analysis as to how the
average weekly wage compares to certain
things so it's a little bit more nuanced
I would say than just a strict 60% right
thank you very
much all right seeing no further
questions uh thank you sir I appreciate
the quick turnaround and the detailed
analysis thank you and I'm going to step
out and hand a gavel over to
representative avalani for the rest of
the hearing thank you thank you Mr
chairman
um Christian cerella I'm guessing from
the insurance
department thank you for being here with
us
today thank you for having
me hello my name is Christian citarella
I am the chief Property and Casualty
actuary at the New Hampshire insurance
department Department I have reviewed
the analysis of the ncci I believe their
range of estimates for the change to
loss cost due to the proposed change in
in in benefit is reasonable and actuly
sound I think it is important though to
acknowledge that the anticipated change
to loss costs does not necessarily
mean uh premiums will adjust by the same
factor uh loss cost are strictly the
underlying costs as Mr fennessy
described these are the underlying costs
that an insurance carrier has to pay out
the claims that that occur loss costs do
not account for other expenses to an
insurance company such as overhead
marketing uh completing Audits and of
and some profit provision each carrier
will likely adjust their premium as they
deem necessary um considering the kind
of business that they deal with as was
mentioned the types of uh the types of
employers that they sell their business
to um and kind of the overall Market
approach each carrier is going to
interpret these changes slightly
differently um
but I would I would so because of all
that I would be surprised if if in the
end the effect of this legislation would
result in an overall average premium
increase of that 6.3% high upper bound
that was presented by
ncci nevertheless I do concede after
reviewing the work of ncci that the
change to premium would likely be
greater than the than than the upper
bound my upper bound last week of 4% so
there is every reason to believe after
looking at their analysis that yes we're
looking at somewhere in the five to six%
effect in the end on
premium so let me be clear passage of
the spill would very likely result in
increased workers compensation loss
costs for the first time in more than a
decade um Mr fen's um chart that he
showed goes back to 2019 but in fact
we've had decreases in our state for
loss costs what did I say third it's
been 13 years so it's at 20 what are we
now 20 25 so it's been back to 2012
we've seen decreases and it's been
consistently decreasing every year with
that one blip was a 2021 where it was a
very very small decrease but a decrease
nonetheless
um so if we do have an increase this
time around due to this legislation you
know that would trigger an increase in
workers compensation premium paid by
business owners throughout the State and
it's important and the commissioner told
me to remind you all that the insurance
Market as a whole is a is in very
difficult time right now that in you
know business owners employers are
purchasing Insurance of many different
kinds different types different
coverages we got they have Commercial
Auto they've got property they've got
general liability that they purchase all
of these other types of insurances the
the premiums are going up workers
compensation has been the one kind of
bright spot in the insurance Market in
New Hampshire and in many other parts of
the the country
where you know premiums aren't going
down as as the loss costs are going down
at the same rate
but but things are very very stable very
um affordable right now and so it's kind
of that one bright spot in the insurance
world and uh the commissioner this
morning wanted me to make sure you all
knew that uh that do we really want to
mess with that one bright spot guess is
the way uh he he wanted to impress upon
you um but again this this is a balance
between you know benefits to workers and
you know to be clear as mentioned New
Hampshire is an outlier when it comes to
that benefit to you know uh wage
replacement um you know nationally but
then to balance the other side of the
effect on premium to employers and so
that's your decision to make um so I'm
happy to take
questions representative K shair and
thank you for taking my question so
um in in the area of insurance is uh
workers comp unique in that it is sort
of what the employer does that has a
larger impact than when you say property
if there's a flood in California
everybody
pays right I mean the
you know natural disasters do affect
property insurance more broadly across
the whole country and internationally
for that matter so because of the effect
of uh costs of
reinsurance workers comp I would say is
a little bit more isolated from those
effects you know to an extent I
mean you know for certain types of
employers and certain types of workers
there just isn't enough experience
within our state to develop their own
rates and so we may look to similarly
situated workers in other states to then
develop and when by say we it's ncci
that does the analysis we review it but
and then we approve it but yes so short
answer yes it is more protected more
isolated than than other types of
coverage yeah follow up follow so again
most of the most of the impa
uh the the rate increase that an employ
a given employer would have is based on
their industry and their history uh and
their ability to change that by being
really focused on safety is that correct
oh yes yes and and I do think that
that's part of the one of the main
reasons that we have seen these loss
costs going down over the last decade is
implementation of safety measures risk
mitigation um and you know just better
practices within the within you know on
the factory floor you know one more Yep
thank you sir thank you again so if the
worker is injured this is obviously uh
you know something not that they didn't
they didn't jump off the ladder this is
an involuntary thing that no one
anticipated and their income is reduced
if this law passes you know to 66 and
2/3 do don't they have an incentive to
get back to work as soon as they're
physically able
right I the decision to go back to
work it it it's it is based on you know
what the doctor is going to approve
right but to Mr fen's
point that the correlation is there that
there there in you know historically
there has been an uptick in utilization
when there's been an increase in
benefits um
gently I'll push back uh to that
analysis in that we're probably due for
an updated analysis in that regard
because it has been a while since that
work has been done and the economy is
different than it was and and and there
are many factors that go into that um
but yeah it is true that if if you're
going to if there is a greater Indemnity
benefit you know that it does correlate
with higher
utilization one one more final
followup thank you so for $110 a week
more uh an an employer an employee might
talk to his doctor and say well this is
really still hurting me is that is that
the
fear intuitively that that seems I guess
that's the logical conclusion that for
some reason and we don't know I mean it
doesn't tell us why it's just numbers do
seem to parallel you know that when
there's a higher benefit there's greater
utilization that seems to be the
intuitive approach I guess yeah thank
you yeah any further
questions um now there was one other
thing if I might I had thrown out a
number last week and I just wanted to
kind of give a little more around that
number and that's the number of writers
in the state I said that there were over
a 100 writers in the state and that is
true there are right now there areund
well as of this is 2023 data there are
112 insurance carriers that have WR that
wrote more than one more than 0.1% of
the market so there are 112 ins
individual insurance companies that are
active in the state many of them are
affiliated so like a you take it in like
a liberty or a Travelers and they're
going to have many different companies
inside that umbrella and so if we look
at groups like an insurance an
affiliation of insurance carriers or a
group of carriers we're looking at about
60 groups that write more than 0.1% of
the
market
so it's still a very very healthy Market
in short sorry any further
questions um I have a few of course
um is there a fear of or an expectation
that if wage replacement percentages go
up that
certain carriers might drop the more
expensive clients that have a
recurring issues with workman's
compensation um I don't I wouldn't be
able to answer that with any level of
confidence I
mean there are representatives of of the
insurance industry at least there were
behind me earlier that might be a
question for
them the change being
proposed this is the way I think about
it you know going to 66 and 23% wage
replacement is very very common that
amount of you know that benefit is very
common around the country every
insurance company that writes workers
comp in New Hampshire writes it in at
least two or three other states and most
of them write Nationwide you know and so
this this isn't in my opinion this is
not this would not not be a debilitating
change to any insurance carrier I don't
I don't see this as the thing that they
would then say no we're not going to
write you
you correct but would that Force more
people off the voluntary market and into
the involuntary Market with for their
experience it would just mean that it
would be no because the involuntary
Market would be more expensive as well
and and this is the sort of thing where
again this is my opinion
I can't speak on behalf of the insurance
companies but as a regulator and just
way I see the the market run it's just
it doesn't seem like that would have any
measurable effect on the appetite you
know on the on the appetite that
insurance carriers would have in writing
business thank you any further
questions thank
you anybody else wish to speak on this
topic we have a few minutes
seeing none we'll close the hearing on
7:44 uh we have a
one we have a one o'clock exec
session and the chairman wants you to
enjoy more than 15 minutes for lunch
so
e
e e
good afternoon
everyone welcome to this afternoon's fun
and festivities we're going to exec nine
bills and uh that that will close us out
until Senate bills and we'll see what
happens
there um
so in the interest of the great amount
of work that everyone's done and and
being completely thoughtful on these
things there's folks have done a lot of
work to make bills more uh compatible
and understandable and as such as my
Deputy reminded me this is my
self-inflicted wound but at the end of
the day I do respect what everyone's
doing and we've got seven
amendments okay so I talk to Paul Smith
this morning just to make sure we got
this right and I just want to review the
bidding for everyone so we can keep
ourselves honest okay so what what's
going to happen if there's a mo if
there's an amendment on a bill the
person with the amendment will introduce
the bill as ought to pass as an ought to
pass motion with Amendment
okay then and then that person will be
given the opportunity to explain the
amendment and we can have a discussion
on Amendment and then we'll vote on the
amendment the amendment will either pass
or fail if the amendment fails then
we'll go to the original motion of a to
pass if a to pass passes then off to
pass and off we go if off to pass fails
then a new motion will be made for
itl or or could be to retain or whatever
the new motion would be all right and
then so we'll go through that now of the
nine bills we're doing that seven times
which is why I just wanted to go through
the
process um as as I've research this more
to make sure that we are straight are
there
any issues with that any questions
comments yes sir of course I just wanted
to express my appreciation to the home
that you did because I was a little
unclear about the process and by the
time we get to the fifth one I think
we'll be good at
it we'll see but no I I did I asked the
question four times I got four different
answers so I went to the mountain and
and I talked to Paul this morning I I
think even if we're not right we're
right enough but quite honestly I think
I think we're good to go okay so to lead
off this
afternoon uh I opened hearing on HB 248
representative Flanigan do you have a
motion thank you Mr chair I do have a
motion I have a motion to OTP with an
amendment and I'd like to have the
opportunity to introduce the amendment
once it's as soon as we get a second do
we have a second
yes yes Warden second and do you want to
speak to your Amendment yes very briefly
because there really wasn't a lot of
changes um if one remembers the uh
lobbyist for the uh uh state employees
union came in because they was concerned
that there was the already existing
language in the CBA that they had uh and
uh what I did was I amended this bill on
the last sentence saying this section
shall not apply to employees covered
under collective bargaining agreements
and that's it and uh I think we met the
objectives that and I think the vice
chairman had some concerns that I
addressed too okay great I appreciate
your doing that work are there any
questions on the
amendment see no questions on the
amendment Mr clerk please call the
role representative avalani yes
representative
Flanigan representative SS yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative Granger hi
representative farington yes
representative Hall yes clerk yes
representative L yes
uh representative alone
no sorry sorry representative Susi yes
representative alone yes representative
kahill yes representative D salvestro
yes representative bushard
yes representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stop Yes representative kraton yes
it's
unanimous okay uh Mr clerk do I have a
motion for ought to pass as amended
yes I motion to O to OTP otpa otpa yes
sorry correct and do I have a second
second Wen and Mr clerk would you like
to speak to your
motion yes I I would like to say that
the addition there changes the as we
talked about the uh
separating the um unions and what they
recommended and also the changes but as
far as it that's why you know that
changes a really good change for this
bill okay and would you like to spe
speak to your second are there any other
comments or questions on this
bill saying none Mr clerk please call a
role okay chairman avalani or
representative avalani
yes representative Flanigan yeah
representative SS
yes representative Warden yes
representative Drago yes representative
Granger I representative
Fairington yes representative Hall yes
clerk yes rep uh representative lb
yes representative Susi yes
representative
Sullivan oh sorry the name
representative bone
sorry representative kahill yes
representative D salvestro
yes representative bushard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stop Yes representative Katon yes okay
it's
unanimous so we have uh 20 nothing is
there any objection to putting this bill
on
consent seeing no objection let's put it
on consent thank you and this closes the
executive session on hb2
uh representative Flanigan are you
you're doing the blurb on
this thank you
all right and I'd now like to open the
session on
hb280 and representative Granger do you
have a motion I move uh Amendment
H you you move you you motion for ought
to pass well I move the amendment and
then we ought to pass I can no we make
the ought to pass and then you talk to
the motion the amendment okay ought to
pass as
amended you you move a to pass and would
like to offer an amendment uh yes very
good thank you and is there a
second I second representative Warden
seconds and would you like to talk to
your Amendment yes so this amendment
just adds the words and employee and
that's just to signify that the employer
and the employee are equal Partners In
The Exchange and that both of them have
the right to walk away from an agreement
that they do not like
okay is there any discussion on the
amendment as
presented seeing no
discussion um Mr clerk would you call
the role on the
amendment representative avalani yes
representative Flanigan yeah
representative SS representative orss
yes ORS thank you
sir uh representative Warden yes
representative Drago yes representative
Granger hi representative farington
yes representative Hall yes clerk yes
representative lbr yes representative
Susi
no representative alone alone votes no
Representative kahill no representative
D sylvestro
no Representative bushard no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
lir no representative stop no chairman
Katon
yes
119 the amendment passes on a vote of 11
to9 representative avalani do you have a
motion to
make thank you Mr chairman I move
otpa on House Bill 280 could you turn
your mic on please thank you Mr chairman
I move otpa on House Bill
280 your motion is otpa
on House Bill 280 is there a second I'll
second that thank you thank you
representative Warden and Mr avalani or
representative alalani would you care to
speak to your motion thank you Mr
chairman um the amendment satisfies my
um curiosity by adding an employee so um
now I like the Bill thank you and
representative Warden would you like to
add anything is there any further
discussion on this bill representative
Susi thank you Mr chairman uh I'm going
to vote against this I think the
legislation is bad I don't think we need
to change the uh the wage payments I
think people are pretty happy at work um
with the way things are um I think this
just some would say it would make it
easier but I think it complicates the
matter so I'm going to vote against it
thank you okay thank you are there any
question representative kahill uh thank
you Mr chair as I recall the Department
of Labor had several concerns about how
this would work if it wasn't in fact uh
valid currency that was used and that's
not specified actually it's crossed out
in the bill and remains crossed out in
the amendment so I'm voting against it
okay thank you for your
input any other
comments and Mr clerk seeing no other
comments Mr clerk could you call the
role on otpa for
hb280
okay representative
avalani
yes representative plan again
representative SS representative or or V
yes
ORS
or representative Warden yes
representative Drago yes representative
Granger
representative farington yes
representative Hall yes clerk yes
representative L yes representative Susi
no
sorry representative uh vone alone votes
no okay representative kill no
representative D sylvestro no
Representative bushard no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
lir no representative St
no and representative kraton
yes
119 all right the vote is 119 and
representative Granger you're doing the
committee
report Roger and representative Susi
okay please and and again as as is our
habit uh by noon tomorrow would be great
that way we can get it in for next
week's
calendar all right this closes the
hearing on
hb280 I now like to open the hearing on
HB
379 and representative Cahill do you
have a motion to make uh yes Mr chair I
move for a to pass as amended and I do
have an amendment uh to speak to all
right and representative lb do you have
a a second on
that uh did Chris have a second it's
better no go ahead uh representative
Schultz go ahead okay a second you
second great and would you like to speak
to your Amendment sir yes thank you Mr
chair uh during the hearing on the bill
there were several good suggestions made
from committee members and I've tried to
incorporate them uh among them were uh
the the change from the during the uh
School uh school vacation week to weeks
because there are a
couple and we also added the uh Monday
or Friday holiday which I thought made
good sense and I thank the uh members
for that
and clarified that is that during the
period in which school is in session uh
so that would be the the time that uh no
youth 16 or 17 year old in the night
work so I I think I've dotted all the uh
eyes and crossed all the tees that were
offered so I would hope that you would
support this amendment and allow uh our
younger workers the time to uh prepare
for their adult work careers uh although
they certainly value The Experience from
this high school year work uh their High
School diploma and further education
will have lifelong effects and that is
why I have brought this bill
forward is there any discussion on this
Bill thank you for your
work seeing no discussion on the
amendment Mr clerk please call the
roll representative
avalani yes representative Flanigan yes
representative ORS yes Representative
wardon no
representative Drago yes representative
Granger
yeah representative Fairington yes
representative Hall yes the clerk yes
representative lbre
yes representative Susi
yes representative alone
no representative kahill yes
representative D sylvestro
yes representative bushard yes
representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz
no representative lir yes representative
stop Yes chairman
kraton
yes
173 17 to3
the amendment
passes are there any discussions on
otpa no we already
have't yeah is there a motion for otpa
representative kill
yep okay are there any discussion is
there any further discussion on
otpa for 2 37 9 representative Schultz
thank you Mr chair I do want to just
take a moment to say why I I voted no
and it impacts the bill now is I don't
think it goes far enough to protect uh
the young folks who were working I feel
35 hours is too many hours in a school
week in my opinion and I think we should
be putting a lot more restrictions with
parental permissions and school
involvement all those things so I didn't
feel comfortable voting for it for that
reason
having said that I would be fine if it
goes on consent I don't know where that
threshold is so okay thank
you any and I'm sorry did we get a
second on the motion for
otpa represent D sylvestro seconds that
motion thank
you like speak represent waren please
like just yes just speak against the the
bills amended I think it goes too far in
restricting
employers and giving the freedom and um
choices that young people need to work
around their school schedules so I will
be voting a hard no on this thank you
okay thank you for your input and
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair I'm going to Echo representative
warden's thoughts uh this bill doesn't
keep in mind homeschoolers and those who
do not attend a typical public school
education which is going likely going to
be the majority in the future and uh
getting those kids in in a real life
work experience in a real life job is
one of the most important parts of their
education and so I would vote against
this bill okay thank
you seeing no further questions Mr krook
please call the
role Representative avalani no
representative Flanigan no
representative ORS no representative
Warden no representative Dro no
representative Granger no representative
ferrington no representative Hall no
clerk no Representative lbr
no representative alone sorry sorry
representative Susi yes yes and
representative vone
yes representative kahill
yes representative D sylvestro yes
representative buard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative l
yes but you Skip
One representative Schult sorry no
apologize representative stab yes and
representative Katon
no
no 12
schz voting now oh
apologize
V thank you okay so we got uh is
everyone 128
82 and the motion fails is there another
motion representative
lb yeah I motion itl
379 the motion on the table is itl for
HB 379 is are there any comments to that
motion I will second that Mr chairman
thank you for the second are there any
comments to the
motion saying no comments to the motion
Mr clerk please call the role on itl for
HB
379 representative avalani
yes representative Flanigan yes
representative ores yes representative
Warden yes representative drgo yes
representative Granger hi representative
farington yes representative Hall
yes clerk yes representative Bri
yes representative Susi no
Representative aloon
no Representative kahill no
representative D sylvestro
no Representative buard no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
lir no representative stock no
representative Katon
yes it's
119 all right and uh itl is approved on
a vote of
119 for HB 379 represent lb youve got
the committee
report and is there a represent k
okay and this closes the executive
session on House Bill
379 I'd like to open the house the
executive session on HB
386 represent kill do you have a
motion can you turn your mic please I'd
like to move a to pass on HB 386 FN
and I do have an amendment then
representative Schultz
seconds and would you speak to your
Amendment please yes thank you uh we
heard testimony uh indicating that there
was a problem with the lack of
information and formed consent with the
um
um sorry with the
uh what's the word I'm looking for it's
terrible uh uh any anyway nurses would
often work for a an agency be assigned
to several different places and each in
every place they work to shift uh they
could know they could no work not be
hired there uh directly by the employer
no matter how much both sides wanted it
without some sort of exorbitant payment
perhaps as for as long as a year or two
and uh we also heard that uh there was a
local uh interim health agency who used
a period of 13 weeks and after that uh
they were free to go so uh that seemed
to be there seemed to be some interest
in that some consensus that those were
both concerns that we could address and
U while if if this does not work I would
hope we would retain the bill but that
delays the ability to to address the
issue and we all have uh we all have
nursing homes in our counties some there
are sometimes correction facilities and
we certainly have schools and school
nurses so this affects the whole state
and I'd like to see us do something uh
this year if at all possible and I offer
this amendment to uh make something
happen thank you sir I appreciate your
work on putting this amendment together
representative Schultz would you like to
speak to your
second um I really think it's import yes
Mr chair I really think it's important
that we acknowledge that these
agreements take place as today between
uh the employer and the agencies who or
the agency and the employers who
contract with them and I think that we
need to make sure that um any employee
uh in this situation understands the the
rules from the beginning about
non-competes and I think this uh
addresses it in a fair
way okay representative Warden would you
like question for the sponsor
please re reading line number one of
your Amendment it reads funny to me to
my reading and it says amend so and so
as inserted by section two of the bill
by replacing it with the following is
your Amendment designed to replace the
entire bill or just section two with
this new
language and if and second secondarily
do you agree that that analysis in line
one is
clunky okay thank you for the question
uh this is intended to replace just that
section and it shall it before the
letter e there should be shall not which
I think survived in the bill and this is
one of the unfortunate things where we
had the amendment only and not the whole
bill in front of
us thank you okay are there any further
questions or
comments seeing
none uh would you please call the rooll
call on HB the amendment to HB
386 representative Avalon
no representative
Flanigan representative ORS no
representative won
no Representative drego no
representative Granger no Representative
farington no representative Hall no
clerk no representative l
no representative Susi
yes representative vone
yes representative kahill yes
representative D sylvestro
yes representative buard yes
representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes and representative Kon no
119 right and the amendment fails 119
we're now back to the original yes
representative K I'd like to make a
motion to retain this bill so that we
might uh explore ways to have this uh
resolved for in the going going field is
there a second as a valid motion is
there a second to the
motion second to the motion is there any
comments to the
motion representative Granger thank you
Mr chair I I think this section of law
is okay as it is and I don't think that
we need to retain it um because we can
just put another bill in next year or
something thank you any other questions
I have one represent McKenzie good thank
you um I think anybody who is related to
the nursing field and the Staffing of
facilities and I Vice chair of the
Hillsboro County
delegation everybody's facing issues
everybody is facing issues uh around
Staffing
questions I think the testimony from the
witnesses that came before this
committee are
compelling to the extent that we need to
take a look at people who are
practitioners in the business Who coming
in front of this committee saying look
we need some relief from some of these
issues I I think we owe that to them
they gave very compelling testimony they
appr Professionals in this business they
not only are they uh nurses but they are
union Representatives who know what's
going on and so I think we got to
respond to people who come in with this
kind of testimony and you know nursing
in general is is a field that's changing
and not in a very good
way all right thank you represent
Flanigan thank you Mr chair one thing I
also heard though was that a gentleman
came came in and testified that he
strikes a business relationship with a
county or a school district or whatever
the case may be
voluntarily and now we want to insert
after the fact that we don't like it
well there's a lot of things out there
we don't like and yeah there's a lot of
things that cost more money for the
towns and the counties and and the
schools
but we're what what are we trying to do
legislate
stupidity I I just don't get the whole
idea of trying to usurp this Arrangement
that's been made and it's made in other
Industries too it's not just for nurses
so I'm having a tough time with the bill
and there nothing personal it just that
it's an ongoing practice and I just
don't don't see it and representative
Drago I'm just going to build on what
representative Flanigan said I agree uh
yesterday we had a few employees call
out so we actually had to hire an agency
to staff us and would you know it as
part of the paperwork we had to filled
at the beginning of the year we had to
sign a non-compete we couldn't hire the
employee outright they had to work for
us for a certain amount of time
rightfully so that the agency can make
their money off us and then then we
could hire them so it's not unique just
to the nursing field it's I think it's
across the board everybody has worker
shortage so um singling out one one
industry is not something I can agree
with okay representative kale thank you
Mr chair um I'd like to point now it's
my understanding that if we filed a bill
in the first year and it did not pass we
can't file it again in the second year
so that means retaining is the best
option if we actually would want to do
something with this bill and further
that uh while uh there certainly are
temp agencies uh who Supply workers and
and they are paid for it uh nursing is
is is a critical part of healthc care uh
you can't just get anybody off the
street and now you're a nurse and giving
medications and our our population is an
aging population myself included and and
I think we need to have the the be able
to open the wards at the at the County
nursing homes not close them because we
can't get people or we can't afford the
people and uh I think we need to work on
this bill I'm disappointed we didn't do
the amendment but let's go forward and
and work on it further all right
represent Schultz thank you Mr chair I
think this is an issue of just basic
oldfashioned common sense and fairness I
mean the situations that we heard about
in testimony to really stick out to me
um the first is the general thing that
we heard over and over again which is
these agreements aren't involving the
employee at all these are between an
agency and who hires the agency which is
a business or private entity whatever
the employee comes in after that and is
often times not even aware there is a
non-compete Clause that will inhibit
them from taking a job at say that
nursing home uh for some years that
seems just incredibly unfair to just you
know if this contract that was signed
separate from you is it presented to you
to let you know that this is what's
happening but the one that re the second
example is the one that just really
sealed the deal for me and that was
someone testified that you know folks
don't even know they're necessarily
taking this interview for a job with an
agency they think that they're actually
working for say Hillsboro County Nursing
Home the way it's advertised to
employees makes them believe they're
working for that nursing home so in what
Universe if we don't at least find a way
to inform them which we could do we
could change the bill if we retain it in
what Universe could we even give a
chance for that employee who is really
here to pitch in and do the right thing
and work in these jobs you know that
would be a fair way to deal with it you
know what I assume a reason to be
opposed to a concept around this to be
okay with this contract situation would
be because you don't want poaching okay
you don't want poaching that I
understand as a temp earli you know 30
years ago I did some temp work I know
what that's like like you know we
definitely had limits on the laws there
on at that point but I was I was aware
of them you know to to not put an
employee in the situation to even help
them understand that they're not
applying for Hillsboro County nursing
home or that this agreement even exists
to me seems incredibly unfair so I if
you oppose this bill I hope you will
seriously consider a level of fairness
to just the average person taking these
jobs to find a way to do the notice
piece because if we don't even notice
the workers and we lead them to believe
that they're working directly for that
nursing home and not an agency and so
maybe it's too late I think that's
incredibly unfair so I agree that I
think retaining this if you oppose the
bill would be really helpful to people
in the granite state and it might
actually make say health care and other
things deeper that's my two cents thank
you and representative Susie thank you
Mr chairman so I think there is a
problem um in general overall speaking
not necessarily with the bill but I
believe there's a problem and I think
retains a good option it doesn't hurt to
retain it there's going to be a little
work to be done and at the end of the
day if we decide that you know retaining
it and we can't come up with anything
then we voted a different way but I
don't think retain is a bad way to go on
this and just take a look and see if
there's anything that we can do to help
this situation out thank you okay thank
you and representative Granger thank you
Mr chair I think the the laws of
Economics are important in this
specifically because nursing is such an
important field and because we have a
nursing shortage ignorance of Economics
is going to be all the worst if we have
a tendency to ignore them uh there's a
mentality in modern America where we
think that just because an industry is
important that means for that for the
reason that it is important we can
ignore econ but we can't it's more
important because it's an important
industry to follow the laws of economics
and if we have these non-compete
agreements banned and or if we have come
out with the bill and retain it and do
all that we're still going to be
ignoring the laws of economics if you
want to have like a notification or
something like that that's should be a
separate bill it shouldn't be part of
this bill and I don't think even if this
Bill gets indefinitely postponed on the
floor I don't think anyone would be say
that uh a notice to an
employee that there's a non-compete
agreement is is the same thing as the
last bill so I think it would be
perfectly fine to file it next year and
representive Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman on a similar note not that I'll
say I say the same thing as my sidekick
here but to representative Schultz's
concern is the bill if it is to itl it
can be brought back though similar to
what representative Susi was commenting
about was it uh
sharing to the prospective nurse or
whatever employee is that there is a
relationship with the the location where
you'll be working at and that you you
cannot just leave us and go work for
them there's a process in place if that
bill was submitted I don't see there'd
be a conflict between this bill in in
something Bill like that because they're
they're dealing with two separate issues
one's the new one one would be this a
notification whereas this is basically
saying you can't do it as an agency so
it's a two different things but it does
the goal I think that the sponsor wanted
was to make sure the person knows that
you can't just take a job unilaterally
now maybe that's the case but I I I
think with the agreements that we have
and uh it creates problems but that that
can be resubmitted next term represent
kill Mr chair I I again that would be to
my my friend Mr Frank and that would be
up to the speaker to decide but I wanted
to add that we did hear from a gentleman
who I said I believe he had over 40
years experience in this business and he
has relationships with the with the
facilities and with the the uh people
that he calls upon and it seems to be
working with just 13 weeks of uh
recouping his expenses and making a
profit otherwise he wouldn't be doing it
for I think it was 43 years so I I think
this was not saying you can't have a a
non-compete it just says the length of
time for which you can have it uh 13
weeks as opposed to 52 weeks or some you
know there's there's no limit right now
so so I think again I think we should
retain it and do some additional work uh
thinking of our of our districts uh the
people that we serve uh this could be
helpful representa
lebrin thank you Mr chair just to sum
this up I think and we've hired
temporary workers too and when we go to
ATT temp service we know how it works
the workers know how it works everybody
knows how it works so to to put on this
charade that we don't know how it works
is a
charade and and I don't know that we
should retain this I think it needs to
be gutted and brought back as something
else if there's truly a problem I think
it needs to be we need to dive into it
deeper this is not the build to solve
the
problem represent
McKenzie let me um let me repeat
this in in nursing homes and and agen
all over the the state and County
government there is this issue and
Staffing uh agencies are an
issue uh they cost more money they
displace workers uh so we need to figure
this out I think somebody comes to us
and says we have this problem we need
this committee which is the charge that
we have to look at issues around
Staffing of uh and how Staffing works
and whether or not this is impeding uh
people's rights and but more importantly
what kind of impact is this having
generally on the workforce and the
nursing profession uh is one of the the
places where there are shortages where
the Boston hospitals are just pulling
them out of the state of New Hampshire
and so if somebody comes to us and said
will you take a look at this I I think
we should take some time we we don't
have a lot backed up here to take some
time to really to go through this and
try to understand uh how these pieces
fit together in the broader question
about uh the impact is this having on
the on the on the business so I would
encourage this committee to retain this
legislation right um
all good
points I think we should listen to it uh
I do believe that the opport I do
believe that as I read the bill that we
missed the
mark and and what I would rather see is
coming in with uh a more specific thing
related to the agency versus the
employee uh next year with a separate
bill and
uh I just listen to everyone and having
read through it that that's sort of
where I'm coming out on it
um any other comments seeing none Mr
clerk please call the rooll on the
motion to
retain Representative
avalani
no representative Flanigan no
representative ORS no representative
Warden no representative Drago no
representative Granger no Representative
farington no representative Hall no cler
no representative BL no representative
Susi yes representative alone yes
representative Cahill yes representative
D salvestro yes representative bushard
yes representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative laclair yes
representative stop Yes Representative
kraton
no
119 all right the motion to retain uh
sales at 11:
to9 uh we back to our original motion Mr
chairman I'd like to offer a new
motion are we ready for a new
motion yes well I think so no do bear
with me here do we vote on our to
pass that was the original motion was
ought to pass and then the amendment and
then a subsequent retain
original motion is to pass rain I
believe that the process is the
amendment is offered then you make a
motion to ought to pass as amended or
you make a motion to itl or an
alternative motion I do not believe the
original original motion when you're are
trying to amend the bill is ought to
pass as amended because you haven't
adopted the amendment yet no no no the
original motion was ought to
pass then Amendment failed the amendment
failed right but no mo mo but so you
make a motion to amend and then if you
want so if you want the motion to amend
to pass and you voted on that that's one
thing but you can't vote to pass as
amended unless noal motion was ought to
pass not ought to pass as
amended the the motion to ought to pass
as amend it was never made because we
did not pass the amendment but in order
to vote on an amendment we need to vote
on whether or not you need to make a
motion to
amend we did and we and it failed 119
right so now we don't now we up to New
motion you can make the the motion of
ought to pass doesn't outrank the motion
of
itl except that theemotion to ought to
pass was never voted on but with the
motion was to amend not a motion of
ought to
pass I the process that we've been
following in this in this executive
session just seems strange to me okay it
it's not strange to me okay so we're
going to vote on a the pass and then if
that passes or fails then we'll make a
new motion I did disagree cuz he made a
motion the excuse me the representative
made a motion to retain correct that
failed now we can entertain a new motion
which I'd like to
move it's not OTP doesn't hang out there
until we vote against it retain was a a
valid motion and it died and it failed
and now it failed now the bill is open
for a new motion as far as I'm concerned
unless somebody can prove me wrong
you're right yeah you're right
so I'd like to move to legislate on
House Bill
386 okay that motion is denied uh Mr
clerk can you call there any comments on
ought to pass which is the current
motion on the table
seeing Don Mr clerk can you call the mo
call the role on the initial motion of
ought to
pass Representative
avalani no representative
Flanigan representative ORS no
representative Warden no Representative
drgo no representative Granger no
representative Fairington no
representative Hall no
clerk no representative l
no representative
Susi yes representative alone yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro
yes representative buard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir
yes representative stab yes
representative Katon
no
119 all right representative waren would
you like to make a motion yes Mr
chairman thank you your motion I move in
expedient to legislate on HB 386 thank
you sir is there a second it is seconded
thank you representative L and
representative Flanigan you beat me to
the button so you're up representative
FL Flanigan
seconds is there a discussion to your
motion no discussion is there any other
further discussion on this bill Mr clerk
please Rock call the
rooll representative avalani yes
representative Flanigan I representative
ores yes representative won yes
representative drgo yes representative
Granger hi representative farington yes
representative Hall yes clerk yes
representative liur yes
representative Susi no representative
alone no Representative kahill no
representative Destro
no Representative buard no
representative McKenzie
no representative Schultz no
Representative lir no representative
stab no representative kraton yes
119 all right uh the vote is 11 to9
represent Warden do you have the
committee report yes sir thank you and
is there a Minority Report
representative kill thank you
sir yeah I have to WR Mr chair I have a
point of order point of order sir so the
uh the chair as I understand it has the
authority and if somebody disagrees with
the chair they can challenge the
decision of the chair and call for a
challenge what we just witnessed there
quite frankly where a member of the
committee was was challenging you uh on
on on your decision I think was
inappropriate and I think it I think it
violates the rules in the sense that you
have they have a responsibility to
challenge you and there is a process
whereby they challenge a chair so I just
want to object to what just happened
here uh as much as we may not agree with
you from time to time you're still the
chair of this committee and you have the
authority to make these decisions thanks
sir appreciate
that all right I'd like to close the the
hearing on
hp3
86 and I'd like to open the hearing on
HP 487 representative Granger do you
have a motion I move itl the motion on
the table is itl for
hb4 87 do we have a second Mr or
representative Flanigan uh
will second it if you need a second Mr
chair did you were aware that there's an
amendment on this that was being
offered I see no Amendment on 487 it was
passed around yeah also Mr chair I I I
sent you an email saying that we would
be offering this amendment did you I'm
sorry if you didn't see it things were
happening at a rapid pace so you might
you might not have seen it
I two yeah we had several amendments on
our desk but I didn't see that one no
I've got amendments on every Bill except
for this one okay
um I didn't have uh representative
kahill's Amendment but maybe it was
floating around yes all on your desk no
no I was looking for
it all right the motion uh on the
table is for itl of HB
487 and given that we we had agreed to
look at
amendments which which I am willing to
do
um representive Granger if if I can you
withdraw your itl
motion sure I'll withdraw the itl thank
you
and uh representative St would you like
to make a motion yes yes and I'm sorry
one second and representative Flanigan
will you withdraw your second absolutely
thank you and representative St would
you like to make a motion thank you Mr
chairman I would like to move off to
pass um with an
amendment and is there a second
representative Schultz seconds
representative star would you like to
speak to your Amendment um yes um I
would like to present Amendment um
0459 which is an amendment to House Bill
487 um which is a um a bill to require
employers to provide schedules a week in
advance so that people can plan their
schedules um based on the information
that we heard during the hearing there
are some
um some positions some jobs that just
don't fit into a regular schedule and
that if this bill were to passed it
would have created a lot of unintended
consequences so the bill has been
narrowed um if you look at um lines 8
and 19 18 and 19 it has been um reduced
to apply just to um people in the um
hospitality
industry and it um requires um
notification um at least s days in
advance of any scheduled shift and that
would be the starting time of the shift
because there was some confusion about
you know how long the shifts were going
and it also changes um section two um
requirements of this section shall not
apply when um Regular operations of the
employee are suspended during
circumstances beyond the employer's
control such as extreme weather
earthquakes um also it would allow for
um employers to call people in um on
short notice if um three buses full of
leaf peers show up at the business and
they need extra people to come on so
those are the changes that have been
made uh to this um a bill and this is
the amendment that I'm offering thank
you all right and representive schz
would you like like to talk to your to
your second no Mr chair she did a great
job okay and are there any other
discussion on this
amendment representa lb thank you Mr
chair I think with the amendment we have
still continue to miss the mark on this
we have hotels restaurants cafes I saw
something on Channel 9 in the middle of
the snowstorm we just had there was a
guy in your neck of the woods in antrum
that stayed open and I just don't know
how you're going to staff that or not
staff it with weather so I mean if you
want to have this type of law go into
effect maybe it would work in a hospital
where it's guaranteed or the fire
department or the police department but
in any of these that are listed here
there's too much there's too much VAR
variability going on here so I'm not for
this all right now are there any other
comments on this
amendment suing seeing yes represent
Schultz forgive me if I didn't
understand you correctly but the section
on weather here is actually excluding
those
situations it's saying that you know in
events of of such of extreme weather and
acts of God basically um not mandating
that it's removing that as a contingency
I think to meet what you were
saying represent wrong on that I'm not
sure representative Bri do you have a
comment thank you Mr chair um and I
won't go back and forth on this I would
just state that I understand that I
appreciate it I just look at the the the
um businesses that are labeled here and
the question would be who then is the
judge jury and executioner on this in
terms of how does it qualify at the end
of the day right thank
you further
questions R M K thank you Mr shair just
a comment really I I while I sympathize
that things can be unti ipated in the
restaurant world and hotels and such but
I do think if uh if the owners of those
businesses were a bit more conscious of
the circumstances of their employees
that maybe they would make the effort to
prepare a schedule and tell them a
little bit ahead of time so that we
wouldn't be looking at bills like this
uh I don't I just don't think it's
unmanageable I think it could be done
there are probably quite a few
restaurants that say you know these are
the days that you work and those are the
days that someone else Works uh and and
it uh it probably works out fine but uh
that doesn't seem to be the prevalence
in the industry and that's why we heard
the testimony from the sponsor and from
her constituent who was trying to uh
work for a living and finding it
difficult because of this uh
unanticipated schedule you I'm working
tomorrow at 5 5: a.m. uh now you tell me
not that she doesn't want to work but
she like to know when she's going to
work thank you thank you
sir seeing no further comments Mr clerk
can you call the rooll on HB
487 the amendment
number uh 0250 0459
Hotel Representative avalani no
representative Flanigan no
representative ORS no representative
Warden no represent Drago no
representative Granger no Representative
farington no representative Hall no
clerk no Representative
lbre
no representative Susi
yes representative alone
yes representative kahill yes
representative D sylvestro
yes representative buard yes
representative McKenzie
yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab representative Katon
no 119 right now we're back to the
original motion of ought to pass are
there any further comments seeing none
Mr clerk please call the rooll on ought
to pass for HB 487
Representative avalani no Representative
flagan no representative ores no
representative Warden no Representative
drgo no representative Granger no
Representative farington no
representative Hall no clerk no
representative l
no representative Susi
yes representative alone yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro
yes representative buard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes representative Katon no
119 ought to pass motion fails represent
Granger do you have a motion to make I
move itl the motion on the table is itl
representative flan do you have a
second yes can you turn your mic on
please yes Mr chair I'll second this
thank you sir appreciate
that are there any further comments or
questions seeing none Mr clerk can you
call the
rule representative avalani
yes representative
Flanigan representative ORS yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative
Granger representa representative
farington yes representative Hall yes
the clerk yes representative lb yes
representative
Susi
no representative alone no
Representative kahill no representative
Destro
no representative lard no representative
McKenzie no representative Schultz no
representative lir NOP representative
stab no representative
kraton yes
119 the motion of itl passes on a vote
of 11 to n representative Granger do you
have the committee report Roger that and
represent St representative stab great
thank you ma'am
and this closes
the executive session on HB
487 all right and i' now like to open
the executive session on HP 542
and representative McKenzie do you have
a motion to make I have a motion of V to
pass as amended and introducing
Amendment
202-02
52h and would you like to speak to your
Amendment information yes please Mr
chairman can you repeat that motion
again well is I well it's let me just
say I I think it's inappropriate because
this came up in another bill it was CA
confusion when the very original motion
is ought to pass as amended no you
you're you're correct stand by stand by
so your motion is ought to pass you'd
like to introduce an
amendment and then we'll vote on the
amendment so the uh it'll be uh ought to
pass and
second
and representative L cler you uh second
a motion yes okay now can you speak to
your Amendment Place sure uh so this is
amendment 02 uh 02
25252 so we have an opportunity here
to improve the unemployment
system which is badly
needed we have lagged behind for more
than 20 years in terms of increasing the
unemployment rate for workers in New
Hampshire this is is the time when we
have the lowest employer rate in 30
years where we have a fund that's that's
not quite 400 million but it's climbing
up it's about 380 somewhat million
dollars so the employers have one more
Notch to go which they probably won't
get to which is the 400 million Mark but
for the most part uh it's a lowest rate
they've had in 30 years and the fund is
in the best shape has been in many many
years a high highest
level what this bill does is to take an
increase six
steps so it brings it to uh
515 and let me say the the impact of
that particular uh legislation
has so right now you hit the top when
you hit four
$41,500 you hit the
top for that you get um you get 400 you
get $427 and you hit the top of the
scale the people in
2003 the claimants qualifying for
unemployment had a wage of
86,5 in
2003 that's a
26% wage replacement rate in contrast to
the lower end of scale which is which
has a
54% replacement rate
if you go to the following year uh it
there was an
885636 replacement rate what this
particular legislation will do will be
to move up that scale and close the gap
on that uh on that
50% or 50 2% which is really the target
to close the gap on that and the the
important thing to note about this is
because the balance is what it is in the
fund and I think it's a three I I think
after this goes through would be
362 but the trigger at $350 million will
not be affected at all so this is not
going to raise the employer's rate it'll
stay the same all the triggers will be
in place
now you heard a couple of things about
mild
recession uh uh there's two things that
they they call myor recession and major
recession and they are
forecast there is no guarantee that
would happen uh but they have an
obligation uh as the UI uh uh has stated
to give you what could potentially be
and could potentially happen in the
economy in the years to come so it's the
best guess it's it's not un it's not
it's informed but it's the best guess in
that case it would potentially increase
the rate uh
22 uh by $22 million if that if that
were to happen but the interesting thing
about that is that even under the worst
recession the major recession the fund
itself does not go into the negative it
stays within that range that the pment
employment security said because at the
end would be the trust fund would finish
at $242 million so there is no borrowing
from the federal the federal government
uh the fund still has a has $242 million
under the worst case
scenario so in all the years I've been
doing unemployment insurance work uh and
I was on the advisor Council for years
i' I've never quite seen this come
together the way it is and it is our
best opportunity to contribute to
people's lives in a way that's
meaningful and to allow them to have
some more money this is not a ton of
money but it helps each and every person
and you and you notice in the
analysis there were 6,000 people had
this been in place that would have got
this uh just for for the the past for
2003 and more so 6,200 62,000 people
would have got it in
2024 this is impactful it's something
that we can do it's not going to hurt
the employers it's not going to break
the fund and it's reasonable uh to move
in this direction at this time because
of the way that this has aligned and Mr
chairman I would urge this committee
this is good work and this is a good
thing to do for each and every one of
your people who are in who are
unemployed and they're I looked at the
statistic there's not one place of
that's represented in this room that
doesn't have unemployed workers so you
got to think about when you bang into
this person in the bank or you hit them
in the supermarket you got to look them
in the eye and say we had a chance to
increase your unemployment benefits and
we turned it down it's not fair this is
not unreasonable and it's not
extravagant in any way it's only
bringing that up few dollars and I think
this is the best time that we can do it
Mr chairman I urge this committee uh to
please bring that rate up to
52,000 and give workers
$535 for the maximum benefit please do
this thank you sir for your Amendment
representative L do you have a comment
to your second uh yes please just just
obviously echoing everything that um my
seatmate here
described for another $108 a week you
know that doesn't sound like a ton of
money but $400 a month you know whatever
that that could really uh help a lot of
people out so I agree with I agree with
this amendment thank you okay thank you
and represent Susie thank you Mr
chairman I agree with my colleagues as
well I also sat on the advisory Council
for two years when we were in the
majority um and I look back and I look
at the what the fund balance is right
now and I look at at the fact that it
hasn't been raised in years and I would
ask everyone in this room to look at
things that haven't been raised in years
I mean if we go back if it hasn't been
raised in 10 years tell me what hasn't
been raised in 10 years in today's
society everything's been raised
everything been been raised but
unemployment compensation so I think
it's time um I think Mark brought did
some good work on this and um I think
it's time to do it thank you
representative Granger and then
representative Leb uh parliamentary
inquiry so when we vote on this we're
going to be when we call the role we're
calling a role on the amendment just the
amendment only the amendment we got to
approve that first thank you
representative Le thank you Mr chair and
if I could ask representative McKenzie a
question yes please um representative
you had mentioned to me that you know
currently it's 427 and I have some
seasonal employees if I wanted to pay
out of pocket to give these guys a boost
you know instead of bringing this to 52
3 or whatever it was could I then give
them a boost where they wouldn't have to
have this ding there unemployment and
could I do that would it be 30% could I
as an employer offset this from a
seasonal employee perspective I I think
that the the way the law reads is that
an employee can make 30% more than their
unemployment benefits that was before
this committee a couple years ago in
pass for a followup so I could
personally shoulder the
load in that case if I wanted
to I I assume you could okay I just
wanted to check thank
you all
right Mr chairman I got one more point
stand by representative
K yeah excuse me Mr chair I I think
perhaps my friend Mr McKenzie may have
under Mis misunderstood the question
that my other friend Mr lry was asking I
okay I I think if I think they're
looking the employment office is looking
at your wages and unless they're going
to give his going to give another 30%
under the table which we're not sure is
legal I I don't think that would be
advisable for him to shoulder the load
as much as much as a nice gesture it
would be if I understood what what he
was getting
to okay and represent
McKenzie I I I do just want to um and I
we probably can speak to the broader
when this in the
amendment but there was raised during
the course of the hearing the question
about whether or not this would cause
people to stay
home um and I think there's some
evidence that that
showed that maybe when when this rate
goes up that that may tick up a bit but
let me say what that does is it gives
people more time to make the
adjustment it's you know I've never been
laid off I don't know what that's like
I've never been laid off but for those
people who are that are trying to
transition we'll say one careator to the
next
giving people a couple of extra weeks to
make that transition and certainly we're
well within the range of the 26 weeks
gives them that additional opportunity
and and to be honest I don't I listen to
the
Unemployment uh people at the UI uh
committee advisory committee they have a
pretty hefty legal
department so if you're found to be
sitting around and you're not complying
with the with the rules uh looking for
work and filing the paperwork and you
got to file two or three uh contacts
week then you're going to get you're
going to lose the benefits so this gives
people a couple of more weeks perhaps a
little more L room to do that and I and
I hope that that doesn't become the
thing that deters people from from
moving forward with this important
legislation thank you Mr chairman and
representative lbre did you have a
comment you good representative
Mackenzie or kale please
yes I just wanted to add that this this
extra fund while we well I think Mr
labor has also assured us that this
wasn't likely to trigger a a lot of uh
abuse of the system I think what we
should know about what it does and if
you're someone who's earnings this much
money and now you're getting this much
money through no fault of your own
you're looking for work you're trying to
make get back to this much money are you
missing a car payment is your car going
to get repossessed how are you going to
get to that Now new job what about that
mortgage are you going to go on food are
you going to be at the food pantry is
that
necessary is that could we could we
could we do something about that instead
of worrying about all these things that
might happen because that's what does
happen thank you Mr chair thank you for
your
comments seeing no further comments this
vote is on the amendment to HB 542 and
representative McKenzie can you remind
me the number for that Amendment 0252
30252 thank you 0252
0252 yes Mr chairman and uh Mr clerk can
you call the role on the
amendment representative avalani yes
representative
Flanigan representative
ORS yes representative Warden yes
representative Drago yes representative
grer
yes representative
Fairington yes representative Hall yes
the clerk yes representative L yes
representative Susi
yes
[Music]
representative sorry
yes representative kill yes
representative Destro yes representative
Bard yes representative McKenzie yes yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stop Yes representative kraton yes 191
so the motion on the table now is ought
to pass as
amended and are there any comments on
ought to pass his Amendment
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair I think that we've had little over
a hundred years in the experience
experiment of having a welfare state
it's sort of turning into a welfare
trampoline and it's good thing it's good
thing have a safety net like a lot of
people think that it's important to have
a safety net however I don't think that
it's good for the soul of a country to
just have private charity churches and
all the other organizations in society
crowded out by the government coming in
and saying you can only survive when
you're unemployed through us because
we've put the churches out of business
we've put the Charities out of business
we need to get back to starting to
respect each other in our communities
and taking care of our friends and
taking care of our neighbors and taking
care of our communities rather than
relying on the welfare state to bail us
out every time uh it's very bad not just
for the P not just for society as a
whole to have this it's for the person
receiving the handout it's it's attacks
on their soul it really it it's it
really just degrades the existence of
their being they're no longer receiving
charity they're no longer receiving a
gift given from the kindness of their
hearts they're getting some money that
was coercively taken away from a
business against the will of the
business holder they're receiving stolen
funds and we've had a 100-year experient
with this and we've seen the results we
are not the same people that we were 100
years ago we were better 100 years ago
we were more moral we were more Pious we
were more righteous people 100 years ago
and we in order to get back to that in
order to undo a lot of the terrible
things we've seen done in the 20th
century we need to start saying no take
care of each other correctly instead of
doing it through coercion and force and
violence thank you thank you for your
comments representative
McKenzie waves off thank you um oh you
don't wave
off I'm composing myself thank
you so I I I think uh to suggest that
unemployed workers are in some way uh on
the do that they aren't
deserving uh of of the system uh of
wages that come out of a system that is
jointly uh that employers buy into they
spend the money for it they understand
how important it is to have a
Workforce uh to M to maintain a
Workforce to support
them do away with that let me tell you
the the experience I have with Berlin
New Hampshire where I got the call from
Governor Shaheen that they closed the
plant when you had four five 6,000
people out of work in one area of the
state
had it not been for unemployment these
were people who worked that tailes off
for 30 years in a
mill these people weren't looking for a
handout they were looking for somebody
to help stabilize their lives for that
period of time and that's what
unemployment does it helps people to
stabilize their lives had that not been
in place during the time that Mill
closed it would have been a disaster in
Berlin New Hampshire an absolute
disaster F people wouldn't have the
money to eat they wouldn't have the
money to drive they wouldn't have the
money to do anything quite frankly in a
place like Berlin New Hampshire so the
idea that these people are somehow
taking advantage of the system that
somehow this makes that this is not a
legitimate uh uh uh system of benefits
to people is is offensive to me in a
whole lot of ways these people are not
looking for hands out this is a system
that works and it has worked for many
many years is since the 40s and I
absolutely think it's the right thing to
do to pass this amendment thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your comment
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
um as uh Mr McKenzie so aely uh spoke uh
this is a system of insurance and I know
that Mr Granger wants to privatized this
insurance but we haven't had any takers
for $85 a year for the the average
premium
uh and if the employer doesn't lay off
people uh that's about where it
stays and for the employee to come out
with not enough you
know what is it 26% of their income and
try to survive on that uh when they're
laid off not because they're taking a
break from work not because they were
laid off something happened and now
they're out of work the work that they
prepared for the work that they did
where they were earning you know
substantially more than the unemployment
check will provide to say that they are
uh they're being diminished their soul
is suffering and all this
drama and and it's and I mean also I'm
going to mention that the Charities
there are Charities thriving in in this
state because we're giving them gambling
money we're encouraging people to go out
and take that small paycheck or that
unemployment check cash it in and bring
it in and play a try sports betting to
see if they can make a living and and I
I wonder if if the the representative
Granger is Allin for that uh damage to
the economy and damage to people's
Souls uh I think we need to make this
adjustment and we should pass this pass
this amendment the bill as amended and I
hope that the majority of the committee
will agree and if not we'll take it to
the
floor right seeing no further comments
actually seeing one further comment
representative Schultz thank you Mr
chair I wait and bance whether or not to
say this and I'm going to go in a
positive direction to thank you I
appreciate your honesty I wish more
folks who shared your views were that
blatantly honest about it because I
think it helps us all clarify our values
regardless I you probably don't think
I'm being sincere I really do appreciate
it um and I would like to extend the
hand to say if you'd like to work with
me on reducing corporate welfare I would
love to do that um I'll also as a
footnote say we are the least Church
going or religious institution going
state in the nation I used to work for a
church not far from here helping the
Interfaith Community give emergency rent
assistance once one-time rent assistance
and we unfortunately don't have that
safety net from the private sector to
take care of uh that at all just for
whatever that's worth but ask your own
clergy it's tough out
there sir for you thank you Mr chairman
uh you know I just find it interesting
being one that I'm just sitting in on
this uh this committee is uh the
personal attacks against uh
representative Granger for his
beliefs uh not withstanding young lady
sitting next to me the
representative uh you know unemployment
is a safety net it's not the it's not
the end
all and I think what repres
representative Granger stated is
absolutely correct we have lost our
moral compass in a lot of ways in this
country and that's the reason we're in
the state of this repair that we are in
take us aid for example $55 million for
Condoms To Hamas or the Taliban I mean
hor that that money wasn't going
for Condoms we all know it's going to go
for so the focus right now is ought to
pass with Amendment on HB 542 oh did I
get off track I'm sorry Mr chairman you
are off track thank you thank
you so I appreciate the decorum in here
I appreciate the candid
discussion Mr clerk can you call a rooll
on a to pass as amended on HP
542 Representative avalani no
representative Flanigan no
representative ores no no representative
Warden no representative Drago no
representative Granger no representative
fingon NOP representative Hall no clerk
no representative Lae
nope representative Susi
yes
representative bone sorry apologies yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro
yes represent Bard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes and representative CRA no
119 to the ought to pass as amended
fails 9 to1 representative Granger do
you have another motion I move
itl representative c ring do we have a
second yes I
second and representative GR would you
like to speak to your motion I'm good
thank you representative C would you
like to speak to your motion no I'm good
thank you are there any other
comments thank you
representative c r could you call the
role representative avalani yes
representative
Flanigan representative ORS yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative Granger
yes representative farington yes
representative Hall yes clerk yes
representative L yes representative Susi
no representative alone
no Representative kahill no
representative D sylvestro
no Representative buard no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
laclair no
representative stop no representative
Katon yes
119 and representative Granger do you
have the committee report I will provide
that thank you and representative Sushi
do we have a uh represent McKenzie
representative mckeny thank you
sir all right and uh I'd like to close
the session on HB
542 and open the session on on HB
735 representative Granger do you have a
motion I move itl motion on tables I
representative avalani do we have a
second yes please and do we have any
discussions on the
motion it seems thank you Mr chair it
seems to have some structural issues so
just itl it Roger that any other
comments or discussions on HB 735 seeing
none representative look uh c r could
you call the role
please representative avalani yes
representative
Flanigan yes representative ores yes
representative Warden yes representative
Drago yes representative Granger hi
representative farington yes
representative Hall yes clerk yes
representative L yes representative Susi
yes representative alone yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro yes representative buard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes representative Katon yes
unanimous is there any objective to
putting this on the consent
calendar Mr Clark have you put on the
consent counter I appreciate it this
closes the hearing on or the
uh the election or the vote on HB 735
represent grer doing the
blur represent grer you doing the blur
yes great thank
you like to open the hearing on
correction I'd like to open the
executive session on HB
744 relative workers compensation and
dity benefits percentage and
representative McKenzie do you have a
motion ought to pass and you would like
to offer an amendment is that the motion
you'd like to make thank you sir and for
your and is there a
second representative Susie
seconds and Sir would you like to speak
to your
Amendment
sure um so as I mentioned in the public
hearing the workers compensation system
has over the past 20 plus years uh maybe
even longer than that now actually I've
gone through a whole cycle of changes
that have not necessarily benefited the
workers and it's been driven primarily
um by
cost um so we have become
the worker in the
system has become
um the way that they control the cost is
by raking back raking back the benefits
66 and
2/3 is to
restore uh a benefit that we had prior
to passage of
1409 uh back in
1993 so this restores
that but it is um only one of of a
number of things that I think should
change and today there is what was
that today there is uh about 100
carriers in the market 100 people
writing this business from what we
understood from the insurance uh group
and and the market is in much better
shape than it ever was certainly it's in
better shape than we when we started
through these
reforms so at what point does a good
Market that's making money at what point
do we start looking at the workers uh in
the system to say okay we restored the
system it's back on uh it's back on a
good track and now it's time to maybe
look at some of those benefits and
that's what that's what this thing does
I I would be here as I said a couple of
days trying to explain all the changes
had occurred in the course of this of
this year these years
um but they were
significant very significant to working
people and this was one of them and we
are the outlier one of the outliers in
the United States that has a 60%
rate and there is room to be able to
increase this
rate and looking back at uh listening to
the testimony earlier from the ncci
the trend has
been it's been the rate has decreased
now there was a year when went up to one
would decrease less than the time before
that but overall the rate has been
decreasing we have not had spikes like
we did in the in the uh late 90s or in
the early 90s the market has has
stabilized the indemnity is coming down
there's safer workplaces today much to
the much to the benefit much the work
that's been done not only by employers
but I by employees who meet on a monthly
basis with safety and health committees
which we advocated for in the law so
it's it's just one thing we can do to
make the system better for working
people who by the way have given up the
right to sue their employer that's a
tradeoff keep that in mind because had
this not been in place the exposure that
employers would have to lawsuits by
employees would be
staggering let me give you one quick
example and I'll be
quiet under the AMA guides which were
adopted as part of the
reforms you you you get so many weeks
you lose a leg it's so many weeks you
lose an arm it's so many weeks if you
were to take the loss of a limb
and go to court with that you'd be very
surprised at the difference between what
the AMA pays and what the court would
pay that's a tradeoff that was made
so at what point where is the Tipping
Point for all these benefits that have
been taken away in contrast to what the
industry is currently making so Mr
chairman I advocate for this I hope that
you will consider this uh and vote in
favor of it and clearly it will increase
the rates by 5 plus per. but the rate
there is room there to increase the rate
because there have been decreases year
after year after year after year thank
you Mr chairman thank you for your
introduction of the amendment are there
any other comments to the amendment
representative
Warden none representative lbr thank you
Mr chair representative McKenzie that
was a very good
presentation uh what I will tell you is
as a small business owner I am getting
personally squeezed left and right in
every direction for everything we buy
including insurance and I would say that
listening to the insurance commission
stating that the costs will go up I just
don't feel that this is fair to push on
to small business owners as they are
taxpayers too that's all I have thank
you any other
comments representa
sylvestro thank you I'd just like to say
that unless you've been in a situation
where you've had a family member injured
you don't understand it from their point
it did happen in my family uh my husband
broke his neck on the job in a small
company and I think we do need to
increase it and I would be supporting it
so please think about the
people thank you ma'am I appreciate that
any other
comments seeing no comments Mr clerk
please call the r on the amendment to HB
744 stand by
what Mr Clark call the RO okay
Representative avalani no representative
Flanigan representative ORS no
representative Warden no Representative
drgo no representative Granger no
representative farington no
representative Hall no the clerk no
Representative lbre no representative
Susi yes representative alone yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro yes representative buard yes
representative
McKenzie representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes representative Katon no 119
the amendment fails 9 to1 we revert back
to the
original motion of ought to pass are
there any comments on ought to pass
motion seeing no comments Mr clerk
please call the
rule Representative avalani no
representative Flanigan no
representative ORS no representative
Warden no representative Dro no
representative Granger no representative
inton no representative Hall no the
clerk no representative l no
representative Susi yes representative
theone yes representative kahill yes
representative D salvestro yes
representative buard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stop Yes representative C no
119 representative Warden do you have a
motion to make yes Mr chairman I move in
expedient to legislate on HP 744 and is
that seconded representative you have a
second thank you m representative Warden
would you like to speak to your
motion no I think we've had good
discussion on this already it's time to
are there any other comments that would
like to be made or discussion points
seeing none Mr clerk please call the
rule representative avalani
yes representative
Flanigan representative ORS yes
representative
Warden yes representative drgo yes
representative Granger hi representative
farington yes representative Hall yes
clerk yes representative lbre yes
representative Susi
no representative alone no
representative kill no representative d
sylvestro
no Representative buard no
representative
McKenzie representative Schultz no
Representative lir no representative
stab and representative Katon yes
119 and representative
Warden uh do you have the committee
report yes sir thank
you and for minor report Menzie McKenzie
thank you
all right this bill is itl on a vote of
11 to9 this closes the hearing on HB
744 and now I'd like to open the hearing
on HB
755 or correction 757 representative
kill do you have a moot do you have a
motion to make
so the motion is OTP and you like to
present an amendment and do we have a
second representative stop
seconds
and
four and represent K would like to speak
to your Amendment please um so the uh
original bill
I'm sorry maybe maybe your neighbor has
them because I did put three on every
desk stand by if you could stand by
represent kill we'll get you I will get
you
one all right everyone got the amendment
represent kill over to you sir uh thank
you sir uh the original Bill uh I was
trying to make it easier for the for the
business owner and the employee to
understand exactly what situation was
happening with the way they were earning
money and the way they might be
Distributing it to their co-workers tip
sharing tip pooling because we find that
there's and as I heard uh Mr Summers of
the Restaurant Association say that this
is one of the Heavy Hitters violations
for misunderstandings is a problem and
they don't want those violations so I
was trying to help him out doing the
best I could to help Mr Summers he's not
here oh Mr V please con please convey my
w best wishes to Mr
summer uh so he both he and the employ
you know employees really should know
what's going on what's expected not
coerced but what how the how the thing
works and I also was concerned because
of a change that happened with uh sp269
in the prior year that uh we did move
the uh uh uh service charge out of tips
out of gratuities and now it's just a
separate thing but I didn't think the
public really might might not know that
the service charge isn't going to
servers because service Char servers you
know uh so I I had that but I since
removed that because that that seemed to
be a bridge too
far uh but what I'd like to have if we
could pass this amended version would be
that the uh the employer uh includes an
example and rather than just uh as
stated or as said example I've had a
little specificity here such as tip
sharing to be written in the same or
famili or similar way to this example
servers tip out a percentage of alcohol
sales to bartenders and a percentage of
food sales to the host another
percentage to other support staff and of
course the business is free to change
the percentages and use whatever formula
they want it's just an explanation so
that the server will understand that all
all that $300 of cash in their pocket or
that uh amount that's on the credit
cards might not really be going out the
door with them that they expected to
give some to the host some to the
bartender etc
etc um so I thought this would be
helpful and that
uh they would keep it now I did eror
here because I I did write to uh my good
friend Mr avalani to ask his advice on a
lot of point and I didn't hear it back
in time so I said that a year would long
enough for them to hold on to this
signed agreement that says they
understand I explain but I've been since
since been corrected that the labor
department has a three-year look back so
that would be one more change that we'd
have to do if in fact we pass Amendment
0454 uh to make that three years to be
consistent with the labor department
rules and uh so that's the amendment and
there we are okay thank you sir and
represent stab would you like to speak
to your
second thank you ma'am is there anyone
any other comments representative
Flanigan sir thank you uh Mr chairman um
would it be out of order to request a
five minute
caucus are you okay with the
H all right let them let the minority
out and we'll have a five
minute fine I won't do it
then I'd like to talk to our caucus for
five minutes all right we'll recess for
five
minutes it might be
two
e
e e
all right uh are we we will now continue
on with the executive session on HB
757 uh first of all I would like to uh
thank my for stepping out for a minute
and uh I appreciate your
Indulgence
um we just had representative kahill U
make the the motion uh and present his
Amendment and represent waren do you
have a comment yes please thank
you reading this amendment number 454 I
think it makes things worse um
particularly line six through
eight or nine where it's suggesting that
it would require a business to keep
record
of so-called
um an example of how the establishment
does the tip pooling and when you put
something like this into statute even
though it's just an
example it's going to be very difficult
for establishments or restaurant tours
or business owners
to um interpret that
thousand different businesses are going
to have thousand different
interpretations and this
says U examples such as servers tip out
a percentage of alcohol sales to
bartenders and a percentage of food
sales to the host and another percentage
to support
staff and just in plain reading of that
I would think that when you're sharing
tips you would uh give a percentage of
the tip amount not the percentage of the
alcohol sales amount or the food sales
amount I don't know you restaurant
owners can correct me there but I think
it's going to add a lot more confusion
instead of clarity and thus I think this
um this amendment is a non-starter okay
and I'm going to be voting against it
thank you for your comments are there
any other
comments representative K thank you uh
Mr chair uh you you'll note that it said
uh in line
five uh documenting the agreed upon
practice and the example was something
that I had in this amendment because
there was a concern referring it was too
vague I think for my friend Mr avalani
that we had an example and said said
example so I thought would have put some
meat on the bones but this is certainly
it is up to the business to just provide
to decide how and their employees to
decide the mechanism and to merely
explain how that mechanism Works in
their
operation uh so I'm sorry if it appears
to make matters worse uh and I do I I
took this example from that uh guidance
sheet that I found where described
several scenarios at which you could do
it there's tips sharing where everyone
gets an equal share there's a point
system but this was the rather than
trying to put everything into the RSA I
thought I would put one just say this is
an example and and remember that tip
pooling and tip sharing as as I read in
this document that I sent to All one is
a is a me is a means of increasing wages
for employees but without cost to the
business owner so that's why we have it
and this is just a way to have everybody
understand what how it works it's merely
informed consent thank you Mr chair okay
thank you for that
clarification seeing no further
comments Mr clerk can you call the role
on the am to HB
757 Representative avalani no
representative
Flanigan representative ORS no
representative Warden no Representative
drgo no representative Granger no
Representative farington no
representative Hall no clerk no
representative lb NOP representative
Susi yes representative alone yes
representative
kahill representative
kahill I'm sorry
yes me
amen turn on your mic and then make your
vote and then and no Amendment there you
go yes thank you sir representative kill
votes yes represent D sylvestro yes
representative buard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stop Yes Representative kraton
no
119 so we are now back to the initial
motion of ought to pass are there any
further discussions on a to pass
motion seeing no discussions Mr clerk
please call the RO Representative
avalani no representative Flanigan no
representative
ores no representative Warden no
representative Drago no representative
Granger no Representative farington no
representative Hall no clerk no
representative li
no representative Susi yes
representative alone yes representative
kahill yes representative Destro yes
representative Bard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes and representative CR no
119 the vote is 9 to 11 against ought to
pass representative flanken do you have
a motion to
make motion it is made is there a second
second Mr chairman representative
amalani seconds representative
Flanigan uh would you like to speak to
your motion I would um as you are well
aware my colleagues here you can see
that I take this issue very seriously I
have a lot of friends that are servers
in the restaurant business I don't think
this is the right bill but it may be in
the future so again um I'm supporting
the itl and representative avalani would
you like to speak to your second I I
think we've debated this bill long
enough Mr chairman are there any other
comments seeing no comments represent or
represent cast could you call the role
yes representa and the motion on the
table is inexpedient to legislate on HB
757 representative avalani yes too
representative
Flanigan yes representative ORS yes
representative Warden yes representative
Drago yes representative
Granger representative farington yes
representative Hall yes the clerk yes
representative Lis yes representative
sus
no representative alone no
Representative kahill no representative
D sylvestro no Representative buard no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
lir no representative stop no
representative kraton
yes 11 gay n the motion of itl passes 11
to9 represent Flanigan are you good for
for the
uh I thought he was going to do it I've
already got one represent farington are
you good for the the report majority
report on the
blur yes thank
you and representative Susi represent
kill kill
Roger all right and this closes the the
executive session on HB
757 all right um and that's nine bills
in two
hours including a five minute break
um and an hour for lunch there you go
what else could you ask for repr
St listen this is a great
afternoon from a process perspective I
know there's winners and losers today
but I really appreciate all the work
everyone did in uh putting this together
um we are now complete with our bills
for the
house uh we'll wait for them to be
scheduled um please submit your reports
by tomorrow at noon and uh we'll gather
those together and submit those and then
it's up to the speaker how he wants to
schedule
them email is fine and and if you could
do it to kraton 4 New Hampshire uh
rather than the the general court one I
I monitor seven emails and I it's hard
enough as it is so I try not to keep
adding new emails to monitor Katon 4 NH
at gmail yes
please uh any last thoughts
aliis thank you everyone appreciate all
your
work nice working with you Mr J thanks
sir appreciate appreciate your time
today sure thanks
for for